my one-hour comedy special the Machine
airs on Showtime November 11th at 10:00
p.m. that's right everybody I am very
pleased to announce my one-hour comedy
special on Showtime the Machine airs
11:11 at 10:00 p.m. so do me a favor
spread the word tell your friends
set your DVRs put it on your post-it at
work tattoo it on your arm watch it in
your machine shirt you can get at Burt
Burt Burt calm and tell everyone the
Machine 1111 at 10:00 p.m.
[Music]
hey guys brand new podcast and I know
you're gonna love this one
but do me a favor spread it on your
social media tell everyone about my our
special the machine on Showtime 1111 at
10 p.m.
all right let's real quick do some tour
dates I'm in Philadelphia helium a 6th
7th and 8th Philadelphia on the 6th at
12 I'm doing a call in sick to work show
get your tickets Philly it is gonna sell
out it's gonna be insane so we have a
Thursday late at night to comics comedy
club the weekend after that the Mohegan
Sun Gotham comedy club the 21st 22nd
23rd mermaids in Fayetteville Arkansas
on the 28th of October Dayton funnybone
my birthday weekend on the 3rd 4th and
5th but the third is my birthday bring
me a present surprise me don't surprise
me with like just you know what just
come to show I'm in Baltimore comedy
factory the 10th 11th and 12th and as I
will say ridiculously over-the-top
non-stop for the next straight month the
11th is my Showtime comedy special the
Machine shirtless 11 11 10 all right
cotton I got a couple weeks off Tampa
improv first week in December Morty's
Fort Lauderdale ebony live New Year's
Eve I have a whole bunch of tour dates
coming up in 2017 that we are locked in
real quick I want to talk to you about
my buddy
Zane lamprey he's gonna be on the
podcast next week but he has a kick
started right now for his Advent
dirty and I absolutely love what Saints
doing he is [ __ ] fascinating so all
I'm saying is there's a link at bert
bert bert calm ok click that link for
the adventure hoodie and buy yourself an
adventure hoodie it's a Kickstarter he
has raised over a million dollars he
doesn't need the money it's a badass
product and you need the product that is
the way I look at this he did another
one called the drinking hoodie and it
[ __ ] was the number three selling
product ever on Kickstarter I think now
he is number one he is putting out good
products that's why they're selling so
go to bert bert bert calm go to bert
cast calm find the link for the
adventure hoodie i posted it on my
twitter on my facebook it's simple as
that I'd give you the regular link but
it's a Kickstarter link and it's a
little complicated so just do that go to
bert bert bert calm or bert cast calm
and get yourself an adventure t watch
the video of what it all offers
Zayn's a solid dude so go get it right
now today is my 200th episode of my
podcast my beautiful wife Leanne is
sitting right behind me do you want to
say anything Leanne yes I want to say
I'm very proud of you
are you really I am really proud of you
dude that's a that's a big deal two
hundred is is really amazing I'm
considering other people have done a lot
more I'm still proud that I stuck with
it me too
has it been a pain in your ass no not at
all not at all man it's such a beautiful
way to hang out with friends and have
conversations with people I haven't
gotten an opportunity meet or talk to or
sit down with for a long time right yes
who's but who's your favorite person you
met in the two hundred miss Pat really
mm-hmm miss Pat lover lover who's number
two number two probably Bob or bill or
bill or Tom bill or Tom what a perfect
segue there you go
so to celebrate 200
I thought I would talk to two of my
older friends in this business and bring
them in and no pretense have cigars a
little bit of bourbon and sit in my man
cave and just [ __ ] and man I've sat
through 200 of these a few more than 200
there's one with Alison Rosen that we
had to delete but there's a few that we
had to delete and there's a couple I
lost but the this is a great one it
really is if you're a fan of me bill or
Tom you are gonna absolutely love this
conversation I giggled harder throughout
it and I think this is gonna force me to
step up my game and and really bring in
friends that that don't get to hang all
out enough and have a few drinks and
have some cigars and just [ __ ] for
two and a half hours ladies and
gentlemen the 200th episode of the Bert
cast and if you have it would you please
rate review and subscribe
that's so 2014 ladies and gentlemen the
tip the 200th episode of the Byrd cast
please welcome my good friends bill burr
and Tom Segura
[Music]
I think all our check check - to check
yeah there you're really hot okay you're
- Tom's 1mm let's go - say it again
I'm right here checking you one two
three
no it's not working how come I don't
know right cigars out talk again I'm hey
hey number one you're number one my bag
is working all right bill talk hello
hello Bert Kreischer okay all right and
I'm recording and we're recording
perfect gentleman thank you very much
for doing this this is my 200th episode
congratulations Bert Kreischer very
proud of you man yeah I'm really excited
are you guys friends again you're both
looking good man you both look like you
dropped some weight 15 for me
there you go about 20 that's good shame
it's bad like this there's an art to it
yeah it works for us yeah it really kind
of like Tom and I both talked about it
we were both like in the middle of it
like we're like this actually works like
I mean you start feeling like this if
you feel like a if you feel embarrassed
by something that's my embarrassment
work so get you to change yeah shame
shame works she wears this very powerful
tool yeah it's like the Gordon Gekko
bullying radio show where they're like
so you guys are like good friends I was
like yeah of course I go you know it's
all it's like it's all for fun they're
like but you just did classic bullying
techniques on stage he goes how that
work out for you [ __ ] your head up in
the oh are those like yeah folks your
head up with the bullying like when we
started when the campaign started I'm
saying - Tom I was like initially you're
like ah I got thick skin this is funny
I'm and then one day I read someone
someone's tweet about me and as I was
ordering mayonnaise how can I get extra
mayonnaise and then I read it and I was
like oh this is all very real I was like
oh [ __ ] this hits home
haria this you start reading it enough
you're taking on water something's gonna
get here you know no matter how yeah how
watertight you make it somebody's always
gonna get in it all depends it all
depends on like the mood that you're in
like right now like watching football
and everything is you know the Patriots
are too and oh I'm trying to enjoy this
the Colts are Owen - I just feel like
the football gods are agreeing with us
and now you got all these dopes going
like okay you could put anybody in that
system and they keep bringing up Matt
Cassel yeah
cuz he had an eleven and five seasons
yet to hell with Tom Brady's six Super
Bowls four victories you know yeah this
guy went 11 and five and missed the
playoffs the team that went 16 and oh
the year before in the regular season he
only won five less games sorry I just
totally shoehorned that in there this
Garoppolo guy you know it just bothers
me like just still duh I it really
shouldn't because I think it's just all
envy and jealousy it's the greatest
coach quarterback combination ever but I
but individually then you can have an
American Tom Brady's the greatest of all
time I still say Joe Montana took him
for to win for yeah you know yeah but
there's a good strong argument for Brady
though - there is I mean if you said he
was 2/3 making up Johnny Unitas - Johnny
Unitas threw for over 40,000 yards when
nobody was throwing the [ __ ] ball oh
yeah yeah Marino underrated Dan Marino
needs to be brought up just because
there's no ring if they had one ring if
you hadn't won that Super Bowl he would
be always mentioned in the conversation
people that live through it and that
really like Florida guys you remember
how [ __ ] unbelievable that dude could
wing that thing he beat the 85 Bears
yeah a Monday Night Football that's one
of the greatest games I ever saw where
he beat the 85 Bears baby five Bears
went 15 and won one of the great Super
Bowls that never was was dolphins were
in the AFC Championship a game against
the wild card New England Patriots we
had one in the the Orange Bowl and like
20-something years isn't even as a
Patriots fan as much as I enjoyed that
we finally won there yet like as a
football fan Dolphins got to win that
game play the [ __ ] Bears
yeah they suppose us we went up three to
nothing I don't think we scored again
for the rest of the game lost like like
I remember I was like forty four to ten
or so that that that Super Bowl defined
how I viewed the Patriots until Brady I
feel like you know it's all like your
age affects how you see like pop culture
things like television shows music and
sports I mean the Patriots
for the longest part of my growing up
we're such dog [ __ ] dunno like that was
like played in like a division to a
football stadium yeah it's so it was
almost open on both ends it was all the
aluminum seats you stand during the
wintertime when the coats got all puffy
and stuff with you stood up too long
after a play you lost your seat and then
the running joke was everybody behind me
died out in front they'd throw [ __ ] at
me and he just had to take it so then
the next good play you know you you sort
of watch it and want to sit down because
you'd want to be that guy again no wait
no I used to be aged this [ __ ] on on
like the fact that all the stadiums were
getting upgraded and that we were losing
all these great stadiums yeah until I
started going to Rams game holy [ __ ]
dude the Coliseum the bending in
Coliseum is like Deadwood really it is
disgusting it is it looks like a swap
meet like it's tennis no air cadet
you're sweating in the tent I got a go
there though man cuz that dissipates the
first two NFL verse AFL which became the
Super Bowl games yeah for me that sucks
about the Memorial Coliseum is that they
have that [ __ ] track going around
from the Olympics right yeah yeah so it
makes you even further away about that
Virginia Tennessee game they played they
go sake that you know that Bristol a
race track yeah yeah oh good can we get
any further away when they took the air
suction oh yeah it looked amazing they
had like these stock cars I think parked
to look like a racing oh really I think
that's what it was I just saw like a
helicopter like overview of the thing
it's not the Colosseum's aggressive
there was nothing like watching games do
you ever go to the Orange Bowl yeah
Stadium in a part of town was barely pay
you could buy you could buy crack on the
steps walking in and there wasn't a bad
seat in the house and
tore that [ __ ] thing down I clearly
when I finally saw it how small it was
yeah it's like or the Rose Bowl because
there was no no luxury boxes anything
people were smaller and they just jammed
there was that got just a hundred
thousand people all sitting in these
these circles that just gradually got
bigger and bigger and bigger too they
went see out some Rose Bowls don't think
I've been the rose well I'm up there
with you yeah you took me up yes for the
memory [ __ ] I really wish that I went to
the Orange Bowl that's one that I wish
that was awesome didn't this guy left
the national championship game at
halftime put it this guy oh that's a bad
story girl are too [ __ ] up a little
mix of all of it I get I get four
tickets
probably IMAX sound like six grand with
the tickets a lot of money I mean I get
like a bus for us cuz I'll get like an
old lamb because you went back Florida
State oh I went real big I was so big
that when we got there to the hotel
while my friends start smoking pot start
drinking I think we passed around I
think you brought achieve at you as I'm
walking up and when was this you guys
know each other before this is 2013 the
Rose Bowl yeah oh it sound like some
shitty to when you were 22 I didn't pay
my self two or three kids this is how I
knew that he was on his way to being
[ __ ] up is we mean at this hotel and I
can I'm walking around the corner and I
can hear him in like you know how he
gets more giggly the more [ __ ] up he
gets podcast so I'm walking around the
corner and he's getting them on board to
like [ __ ] with me you know so as I walk
around the corner I go I can hear he's I
was oh World's Greatest Dad t-shirt yeah
yes oh I get there we mean like we we
tailgated for hours yeah
I mean a man who was a long we going
from put and I'm running into everyone I
know and as useful in my life everything
is good like the time you want to you
want it your friends from college to see
you when you're in the middle of a
series you're on tour aw it's just
everything's working perfect for me and
then we get in the game I get Tom and
sit with my buddy Tyler they're in
different seats I'm with my buddy
Eddie and my buddy had Herman and I and
they throw the [ __ ] spear and I start
crying and I'm [ __ ] two beers in hand
and I'm like this is this is it this is
it and then we start losing and this
voice in my head goes you have to get on
a plane to Munich in the morning you
need to get the [ __ ] out and be with
your children and I'm like I'm like
don't listen that voice and then we
start losing more and I was like you
know what you had your fun go home sit
with your kids get on a plane fly to
Munich in the morning I go from Munich
to I gotta go I gotta go a hell of
skiing in 24 hours so I'm like you know
what I think of my friends I get some
beer and they're like we do I go awesome
and I just walked right out
I got an uber start driving home I pull
up the girls are here I talked to Tom
and Tom goes are you watching this I go
what he's uh wait where are you and I
said I'm in an uber I'm going home he's
like Wilson takes the kickoff Oh [ __ ]
hundred yards of the house I mean that
section that I was in I almost killed a
guy out of joy like I grabbed him by his
shirt-collar
and he was giggling and I mean I was it
was pandemonium dude I came home and
Leeanne on the girls or the mancave and
they got the game going and Leanne's got
a beer for me and she goes you're gonna
need this
I said why she goes this is the greatest
football game I've ever seen and I don't
watch football at all and George is
going I can't believe they're gonna win
I mean my kids are into it I'm like oh
my god the Georgia goes why did you go
you're a good dad that [ __ ] went
almost died - hello skiing the next day
I miss that game are you I think I want
to say you and you went well no Florida
State for Auburn yeah
Jameis Winston and was was
what's-his-face with the Panthers
already knows a good-looking guy whose
mom used to tweet remember his mom used
to tweet and his mom was kind of hot he
had the [ __ ] gorgeous girlfriend he
didn't make it in the NFL if this is the
description the Alabama quarterback
quarterback was the good lookin now yeah
not at the time he's not a good-looking
guy was it I know good-looking guys -
the national championship game after Cam
Newton yeah yes I'm positive
Trey Mason was a Heisman candidate he
lost to Jameis Winston I'm a hard look
right now and Trey Mason scored a
touchdown in the fourth quarter with
like maybe two minutes left and did the
Heisman pose at the camera like should
have been me and then Jameis Winston
drove down the field and threw to Kelvin
Benjamin who caught it like nine would
have 12 feet in the air
to win the game yeah yeah episode was a
great game it was an incredible game
only I think of the last 1012 years
probably second best to that USC Texas
national championship game yeah yeah
that was the best one I think that's
what I heard convincing another one I
didn't really go hardcore I was a
hardcore into college ball in the 80s
90s I started comedy and I just I kind
of got away from a lot of sports other
than you know I don't know some of the
pro [ __ ] I would always watch the Super
Bowl the World Series and that type of
thing but I was just I was living on the
East Coast and just every game starts as
you're going out yeah just miss
everything it was until I came out on
the west coast you know seven dad I got
back into it and I just said I got to
pick a team because coming from
Massachusetts you know we see
bu which doesn't even have a football
program anymore Harvard yeah I don't
watch the Ivy League yeah of course not
yeah [ __ ] linebackers are my size and
I like Les Miles because he just you
know just got that Ford weird a class at
the SEC football so when I jump on the
Alabama fan when it's too much fun too
but that conferences is the [ __ ] then
I'm going to LSU Florida and the swamp
human couple weeks really great I got a
big one every year about bill that I
picked up on a few years ago because I
love college ball so much is that he
hits these games and like you'll do a
gig around it right well you'd yeah I
went to Notre Dame USC last year
wow dude I've been to Michigan Ohio
State in the big house I went to the Red
River game Oklahoma versus Texas so
Alabama so Alabama in College Station
against Johnny football Texas A&M [ __ ]
really and then I pick up random ones
like I went to UN UNC last week against
James Madison University just [ __ ] like
that you drink at the games if there if
I ever show that night I don't yeah but
usually like the gig has already
happened
yeah the next Friday night I mean dude
do I drink at the game I mean like yeah
that I leave and freak myself out at
halftime but I definitely I've gotten
into I went to Miami versus Florida
State in when I was a couple of years
ago and I was just rooting for Florida
State I came to the Florida State was
winning so I always root for the home
team
he's Florida State people were talking
[ __ ] I just hate I so hate when people
talk [ __ ] in the home team's place that
I start acting like I've been a
hurricane fan my whole life I said John
with this guy and just like virzi was
better he's like dude what are you doing
he goes you don't care about these teams
I go so why'd you [ __ ] come in
oh my god you've been Oxford I went to
the Egg Bowl once the Mississippi
Mississippi State game no I'd love to go
to that that was [ __ ] I just can't
deal what's the home team that has the
cowbells I couldn't that's Mississippi
State so uh but go to Ole Miss go to Ole
Miss Jackson Grambling game yeah that's
all black just shot at the halftime show
yeah yeah it was who's number one in two
draft picks yeah yeah I just feel like
those games like that like my kids Stan
Stanford's band with their [ __ ] like
their whole [ __ ] like oh we're gonna
do whatever like they're they've already
the greatest band ever so now they're
just gonna do this avant-garde [ __ ] it's
like do when you're as good as the
Grambling band yeah then you can go out
there and play farmers only like with
the Rose Bowl last year and they played
farmersonly.com which was funny but like
when you go there and there's like
families and you just see them like it's
like you're supposed to be an ambassador
of the state these people came out here
why go out and be the exact [ __ ]
thing that they think you're gonna be
like oh I live near an ocean I'm better
than these [ __ ] people are growing
our food I like I like to push back in
the farmers only we're now they're
[ __ ] on city girls it's like yeah
yeah they should go even further this
you have little herpes sores on them I
should be a cokehead of date rapist yeah
they should just do they should if
you're gonna do it total steering I'm
probably being too hard on the Stanford
ban but like because I was an underdog
I told you I just I take on the
personality I got so mad at the TCU fans
one time I don't care about any of these
schools I was just there and they would
they would dress the guys were all dress
like [ __ ] junior Ewing they'd have
the Blazer wear and they go come on in
the girls well come on TCU and you could
tell they had money yeah these would
look like the Christian white [ __ ]
upper-class money yeah they just they
just bug me Oh turn around I'm trying to
stare down some girl and she just saw
him you know iyslah time just goes
my face oh my god I deserve would uh I
want it I've always this is gonna sound
there's gonna be the part of Bill that
doesn't exist I always want to Betty we
talked about empathy no no I wanted to
get famous enough so I could get on the
field and do like that Chris Farley type
of [ __ ] for a Florida State game like
you boss my stomach I like like I'm yeah
I've always wanted that you can do that
it's not about a lot I've a sitcom I
need once one sitcom what the whole
throwing out the first pitch thing man
that's have you gotten to do that yet I
done it I've never done there you have
done it I got it I get definitely
different I don't want to [ __ ] do it
really I just but you love you love all
that [ __ ] but I always just feel like
when I don't be that guy interrupting
the game
you up like the Sox have never hit you
up for that
no and I'm not put throwing this out
here cuz I want to do it I get that I
want to be in the bleachers right but if
they did you wouldn't do it if they said
will you throw out the opening pitch you
turn it down yes because why because I
think that that it look if you're just a
super super [ __ ] huge fan I get it
but I have a big a big rule on doing
extra TV yeah I really believe that when
people listen to you they should be
seeing you doing what you're doing yeah
all right I don't know how it helps you
to get courtside seats and people sat
down to watch the game and then they're
looking at your stupid face it's just
sitting there in better seats yeah then
99% of people and you know you're gonna
be on your iPhone cuz you're testing
your friends like I can't believe I'm
sitting here yeah well you're gonna see
you on TV and you gonna be living like a
douche who doesn't appreciate the
tickets yeah I don't see the upside
yes dude there's no more fun you know I
like sit in the upper deck on a football
game because you can see the whole fear
what you can't see on the TV you know
you can see the defenses and all that
I'd rather sit up there and people up
there funnier the drunker so I don't
stand out yeah it's great
see I I liked I did the take me out to
the ballgame a few times for the Braves
I'm gonna say for the Cubs only we
[ __ ] Bill Murray no no no for the
Braves for the Braves
and then I did I did take me out to the
ball game for for the for the Nationals
and I did the play ball let's play and I
held it I held it for like 30 seconds
and the place when it started going
[ __ ] nuts like yeah it was so jazzed
yeah but dude you're you're why did
they'll you tap in your cigars you guys
are animals
no no touch out of a cigar no no when
the time is right
I'm a little [ __ ] Cigar Aficionado a
fiction out with Bobby in a while Bobby
Kelly ya know last time I saw him was
was years ago on he's like use it on the
East Coast we never overlap anymore
he's on a show now right we're done yes
he is yeah Bobby Kelly is one of the
most interesting people cuz he always
has
whatever the coolest technological gear
is and he's like always fiddling with it
he had this thing called me bow and this
is the thing in six weeks you can buy
him buy it off him for cost because he's
buying the next thing yeah if you if
you're a tight [ __ ] and you don't want
to spend money on technology become
friends with that I live with that guy
for like three years in New York and I
spike I lost count
well maybe not laptops cuz that was
still a lot of money nobody you remember
he used to buy I used to buy four before
the Phoenix given with iPads they used
to sell these like weird things that
Office Depot that were like almost
tablet II type things and Bobby had
every single one that ever came out
you don't seen with a branded thing I
saw him on Opie and Anthony European gym
the other day with the new backpack have
you seen this no but I know but I know
like GPS or something no dude he is like
crazy with technology stuff crazy into
it this backpack I'm not [ __ ] around
it sits on the front of your body like
oh my god but then you almost see Bobby
doing this look I plus button ting and
it falls swings around his back and zips
up like Inspector Gadget he was now it's
a backpack
and he [ __ ] loves it he thought - he
loves it - I like watching SWAT you're
like yeah lot yeah all of those guys
what they what they were big into like
into all of that [ __ ] and I regret I
never got into it because now I'm so bad
with computers yeah like I I can't I
can't do anything and I I do you know I
have my wife right she called me up
because you know she I was on the road
she was paying the bills and she goes um
just this weird tone of voice she goes
why do you have three cell phone numbers
here we made three cell phone numbers
she goes on your bill here you got three
cell phone like I'm no I don't I got one
she goes no you got three she goes you
[ __ ] around on me and I'm like no
right so we ended up [ __ ] looking up
you know what it was
do you ever back in the day when you had
to be at a pay all that money like you
still do if you when you go to the
hotels ah you have to pay for internet
so remember those little things they
look like a mouse and it would be like
your own little internet feed yeah and
they came with the number yeah right so
I remember I bought one I lost it and
then I bought another one
dude I'm talking like oh three oh four
or whatever like fifty bucks a month and
I got nine that's fine it's fine
Lanie's fine and I just said I was like
Mia I would rather pay 50 bucks a month
then get on the phone and be like if you
go to do this I will give them 50 bucks
a month to not do that yeah just to not
do it I mean maybe I maybe I should I
should probably do I should have her do
it yeah I have no patience know like I
was trying to get on like we're having
our kitchen redone and so we just were
around the corner in this little house
and in the [ __ ] guy doesn't have he
doesn't have he doesn't even have basic
cable so I'm trying to figure out how to
get the NFL on my laptop and I'm just
sitting I had to get myself in the mind
space and I called it up and I'm talking
to the robot lady and I got through
every [ __ ] question and it's just
going smooth smooth smooth and smooth to
the very last one this thing [ __ ]
heard me everything I said all right and
it gets to the very last thing they like
so you want to do XY and Z say
yes or no and I said yes then it goes
I'm sorry I didn't understand I mean Lee
as it's talking I said coke
yes keeps going I'm sorry I was in the
house by myself going like screaming and
I just find that a young person and then
upon hitting zero I'm sorry I didn't
understand that right and then finally I
got to a person and it was such a
pleasant experience yes I do today
what's the problem I said I'm 48 years
old computers I can't figure this out
and she laughed and then we just know
it's just when we went into it but like
I still I'm still paying that fifty a
month though I ate a month that she's it
looks great who the [ __ ] looks at the
bill yeah never never know it's just
what is it here you go
yeah Wow I talked about that my dad is
off the charts yeah that's all it ever
is yeah I've never uh I'm really bad at
anything technological but I feel like
there's two types of people who buy a
fan or like buy a weed whacker or
something buy a thing and then pull out
the directions first and then start
pulling it out of the box right I pull
it out of the box and I'll start going I
got this and like I'm almost like
panicking like I got this I got do this
I don't like yeah I tried to put
together a weed whacker and it was like
there's always that [ __ ] screw that
is not coming out after you put it in
and there's got to be something behind
it oh this thing this thing goes because
we got all these Mexican guys in the
backyard doing the house IKEA screws
once they go into that little [ __ ]
crescent moon thing whatever the hell
that is this thing was so easy bill all
I had it had the head like a bunny ear
so you just turn the screw yeah
and I'm turning it and I'm tightening it
and I'm like hit the handle where you'd
hold the weed whacker
it just isn't tightening it's just
sliding around and I'm like buck lemon I
go when I get a allen wrench got to see
a thing and I start trying to tighten it
with an allen wrench somebody got to
stop and look at the design LeAnn's
going let me just ask one of the guys
one of the guys is what they do you're
like I'm not [ __ ] don't because it's
embarrassing I'm working I'm or
maskull ate it because I'm not doing
anything I mean you're doing kettlebells
and running on a treadmill they're
literally tearing apart a house and
you're [ __ ] we're all white and
entitled and should I'm doing podcasts
like they're [ __ ] out there busting
their ass they probably have no idea
what I do for a living I just go back to
this room giggle and then leave he's not
white and entitled he's he's white trash
from Florida this you're looking at a
self-made man it's almost too much it's
like literally like well if they were
gonna redo Joe Dirt they could shoot the
[ __ ] opening scene in the front yard
they sure okay it's horrible so they're
like finally the one of the guys sees me
fiddling with it and I cry and I just go
I can't get this tightened he's very
calmly goes it's so you can move it cuz
like on a weed whacker you yeah you do
this but then you can also edge with it
you can turn it to the side and edge so
you want that hand to swivel and I
[ __ ] sitting and trying to fix
something that I got extra for right
alright extra for a swiveling hand yeah
yeah I'm fun and it was like just so
they can rebuild the house can can they
do a podcast I don't probably it
probably do everybody has one at this
point would have a great [ __ ] podcast
just listening to me have asthma attacks
I would love to listen horrible in there
they do you I don't feel I'm ask you
like can do [ __ ] like that
I actually just praise the hell out of
them but wait I just didn't when I see
like them putting up I can do what [ __ ]
you could you can [ __ ] like you think
you could like okay you're off the road
for six months just the way you're
trying to spit out this sentence is the
way I [ __ ] build [ __ ] yeah they're
just gonna like okay here we go
yeah do you think you could build a pool
in your backyard build a pool like dig
one and if I said to you you got to
build a pool biggest smalls you want I'm
gonna start it off you you're in your
backyard is not the dumbest only easiest
question of my life no build a pool I
love you know what you're looking at you
with contempt and how done your question
so I'm waiting for the funny left turn
you like okay okay how about this do you
think your bath I could talk and pick it
up out of the
wait now why don't you think you could
build a pool I've seen those guys you
got to get down there with the hose with
the cement that huh you could rent one
of those night yeah you ran it for the
day figure it out you don't think you
can build a pool look I don't know how
many times can I answer this nope you
know do you think like you think you
could build do the renovation like I
look at this I go I bet I could have
[ __ ] done some of this like this this
is what I can't get past okay I could
learn how to do some rough [ __ ] all
right but at the end of the day it's not
gonna be as good as if I hired a pro and
it's my house yeah why would I do that
it's like I'm gonna do surgery on myself
or call a doctor knows what they're
doing like I like I you know there's an
art form to everything yeah okay and I
don't want to be an open mic or plumber
going yeah so what else is going on is
I'm [ __ ] crazy she's crazy they
[ __ ] blow out my fuse box or whatever
yeah dude like it's like that's such a
level of disrespect for the art of
carpentry electricians plumbers those
guys like if you get a great one like
what the same way this hack comedians
this [ __ ] biz you know like why did
you ever think that you're gonna be good
at plumbers you know like plumbing
plumbers you know but like you have to
respect what it is I think I'm respected
but I think I could you know get a weed
whacker together buddy yeah yeah I guess
maybe I definitely couldn't do it the
most I've done is actually a pool the
pool yep didn't your dad you should have
started like could you finish a basement
I would have maybe thought even start
below that like maybe your dad do that
[ __ ] when you change the locks on this
time to build oh yeah and I watched my
dad gradually get better and better and
better he built an entertainment center
at one time like I mean he didn't finish
any of the wood it was just plywood and
from two-by-fours and stuff it looked
like a tree
for stains it it was hideously ugly and
like it would none of it like matched up
I finally asked him that like he builds
[ __ ] yeah built this barn that looked
beautiful but one of the doors was like
six feet wide the other was like three
feet wide I'm like why I go why didn't
you make them the same size he goes well
the big ones if you want to take the
wheelbarrow out and the smaller ones if
you just want to walk through the door I
know why wouldn't you just make to same
size once because hey you know I I never
liked symmetry I can't why would you Deb
it's pleasing to the eye no but that
[ __ ] he's great yeah that [ __ ] he's
unbelievable but like my dad my dad is
just like like beautiful mind you don't
I mean like he just like that guy you
know he's unbelievably can fly a plane
he can take your whole body apart put it
back together I mean he's a pilot he was
back in the day yeah like a
single-engine yeah daddy worked on
babies with cleft palates today really
yeah yeah so he was out of patience but
he came home working on babies crying
all day oh good god yeah so he's just
yeah he just he's one of those guys he
did he'd do what you did he would just
but he figures it out yeah he figures it
out but then has his own unique way of
going about doing stuff you know yeah my
dad was like that he would just be like
I'll just do this myself and just do it
and I'd look at that like it well you
know what happens and then [ __ ] 60
years later I buy the house that's what
happens and then they go into the walls
right no what the [ __ ] that's what
happened with my place dude like this is
the final room I have to fix dude how
long have you been fascinated by yes and
I bought the house over again fixing
everything that was [ __ ] wrong I
remember the first time I sent an
electrician underneath the house to
handle some of the electrical problems
right so he's like right underneath the
living room and it's an old house so you
can [ __ ] hear everything through the
floor he's in the crawlspace and like
every [ __ ] 15 to 20 minutes I'd hear
him down then he just seemed just to
himself just go that's why you're down
there
it made no sense like they had I guess
this is really bad and a lot in the art
of electricians whatever you call it is
to alight and then like an outlet should
never be running the same thing and like
mine were it's a fire hazard or whatever
but it was just all just like like
however you connect wires someone knew
how to do that but didn't know any of
the code or anything and it was just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show yeah I had like cloth
wiring down there like some of this [ __ ]
was flashing when he turned on a little
burst of flame would come out there was
a small gasps Jesus oh yeah no the whole
thing I got a deal
a bunch of that [ __ ] for the house yeah
it's like old electrical the electrical
guy was like we gotta do a bunch of [ __ ]
to this house I can tell you right now
before I even walk into a house I can I
can already guess half of this [ __ ] and
that's wrong all right what I first
thing I do is I look if it has the
original old windows in it oh okay and
then if they still cracked around the
side and then you look up at the roof
you look for little water stain marks
and I like I don't even look at the
space like oh my god this would be a
great office yeah I don't look at any of
that I am all looking in the corners and
all of that [ __ ] looking up at the
ceiling cracks stains the whole the
whole [ __ ] thing but the first thing
I look at is like you know obviously if
the things slouching one way or another
but I look at the windows if it has the
original windows I'm like cloth wiring
galvanized pipes yeah nothing's up to
[ __ ] code right we go we had old
windows and they had lead paint them and
they were like and they were like I
remember the guy told us he was like you
know the lead paint for your kids is
really at the time I'm standing next to
eilean tents and he's like he's like LED
paints bad you need to replace all the
windows and I was like what will get
happened he's like you know it's mental
you know like mental retardation or
whatever at the time I was licking my
[ __ ] hand and I just looked down and
I was like [ __ ] put all the windows
in didn't have that many brain cells
left so we put all new windows in then
we just tore them all out just tore them
all out we all new windows two years ago
three years ago now and then we just got
rid of all of them to put to redo redo
the house yeah what happens yeah
eventually you want more space instead
of throwing out [ __ ] you just add more
that's what I do well uh Tom spent three
million on his house Jesus Christ no
I've been telling everyone that it's
[ __ ] two games I'm gonna I'm gonna OH
Kevin Hart I'm gonna tie everything to
do is lie about Tom yeah they lie about
a success to people it's really Israel
he's doing so much better than it is
like mandus see how it started yeah yeah
so what you do is you don't tap it like
a [ __ ] animal all right you just you
just touch it around the side like that
and it comes off keep the see looks like
the Batmobile there any time you see a
guy just tapping it like that
he's a [ __ ] animal and he's not to be
trusted which brings me to you too ya
know it's one of the other either you're
new to it I am totally 100% into these
[ __ ] things and like I read that I
get into this [ __ ] the way Bobby gets
into [ __ ] backpack Cigar Aficionado
out the house oh dude you got is you got
to read the one with Ray Lewis in it
yeah I wish I could have brought the
quote he [ __ ] based he defined what
cigar smoking was he said something like
a man needs isolation isolation time I
came if dude it was like [ __ ] poetry
real Gimenez
scene is like pregame speeches to high
school teams
he'll just pop into some [ __ ] local
to a school and give them a pep talk and
you want to you want to strap up and go
out there when they did that read on the
lines or whatever the [ __ ] it was yeah
about him and he was talking about his
dad never showed up to the game so you
know it wasn't on his life so you know
every rock record I broke was his yeah
just maybe what dude I watched that
thing I went to the gym for like three
weeks in a row just awful watching that
just every time I felt like not going
and this thing my head was like Ray
Lewis would go right now and I'd put
three weeks off of that i watch i watch
rock Instagram videos before I go he's
in the ride that's the most inspiring
[ __ ]
it's
in the morning and I'm here in the gym
in Miami throwing up steel you better
watch make sure you watch what was dealt
to you or you'll get trapped like he'd
add his overpass I want to be his best
friend yeah if you could okay like I was
thinking about this last night stand
hoping Johnny Depp are best friends
if you could get a best friend like
major celebrity major celebrity just
like to be their best friend dude this
town was waiting for you I want a
celebrity best friend I want to get into
the marina just filed for divorce a bit
Brad's looking for drinking buddy really
that would be he's in the motorcycles
dude I love you as his grandfather's
shotgun I had and I know there's so much
about the guy like just I want to have
ABS when I'm in my 50s the 40s and 30s
didn't work out so well
did you just read variety huh did you
just read variety no my wife texted me
that they're getting divorced
yeah dude Brad I google when I started
getting into motorcycles I would Google
pictures of him riding and buy this [ __ ]
he was wearing this gloves - they're
right over there I bought those gloves
those motors Tucker gloves cuz Brad Adam
really look bad as [ __ ] she's riding
that bike he's got the suicide shifter
Jesus and he's [ __ ] dude that guy I
mean he just don't make them like that
no that's why all these [ __ ] people
kind of doing a bit about this these
[ __ ] people that a bitching about
body issues and [ __ ] it's just like dude
and still until they stop making people
who look like that
like they're gonna get those rolls and
they should yeah I am a full [ __ ]
believer in that I mean look if you
stick it that if you can't act but like
the best-looking [ __ ] people without
a doubt you know and I'm fine with I've
accepted that I'm not that [ __ ] proud
go I don't I'll be the guy that Brad
Pitt shoots at a movie I don't give a
[ __ ] if I'm in it right yeah you'd be a
great best friend yeah like especially
going through a divorce and he just
calls you up he's like hey
I kind of offered to go up to crow
territory and ride motorcycles for the
weekend you want to come I got the Jets
leaving in like five and then I go hey
can I bring bill yeah Bert sure somebody
sent me a bottle of wine I want to go at
the bottom of an ocean that's worth 10
grand a sip you want to kill this thing
tonight Johnny Depp Johnny Depp used to
this is gossip but he used to get these
really great bottles of wine by the way
we've really just turned into like
what's what's that guy let's say MZ no
no this is like the antonov Oh Andy
Cohen that's chick ESPN that's chick
sports totally really I've never seen it
oh yeah this show [ __ ] drop I mean
god bless him he's made all that money
but it drives me [ __ ] crazy
I like the gossip stuff I like the
celebrity stuff you don't like it Steve
burned I like it
no I said I don't like it it's just that
like it's just when you're watching it
every night when you're coming home to
it every night oh and it's just going
like so
in episode 2 Mandy said that the reason
you don't have a man and then they just
start screaming and yelling at each
other enough I was impressed with me if
my wife said I thought you were feminist
why would you want to see women just
screaming and yelling each other like
all botox'd up yeah I can't look I can't
look through Instagram too much book or
go like Us Magazine or stuff like that
good you see that life and I go I don't
know I just I guess I thought I would
have a [ __ ] yacht by now you ready
and I just it's so not my cards but
you're also like right ran a [ __ ]
just rent a boat right there oh go from
Marina del Rey up to Santa Barbara and
come back and then you know what then
you'll leave it yeah you know what so
let's say even you had the [ __ ] money
on Annie do you much [ __ ] money just
a crew alone it's gonna cost you like
six seven out of grand a year uh yeah
but do you fantasize about that a lot
for a long time I was really wanted in
Island like I was like I need an island
like I think I saw tree to Branson
yeah and I was like that's that's where
my directions go and I'll be happy then
I'll be a happy you know you know so
funny is I didn't even realize that I
should probably run these gold dreams
past Leeanne
like just I just assumed saying I live
on an island - she's no it's a little
name from well gold dreams and go dreams
these are my gold dreams oh I want to
[ __ ] beach bar I wanna live or retire
on an island it doesn't stand up there
sometimes do you ever fantasize or think
about not working anymore like oh yeah
so because I wonder with like with you
I'm 70 I want to be out is that is that
the out age I know I let me rephrase
that I want if I want to be out I can't
do you think so through the 60s they
better get it again want to be out you
can't like in other words Han like I'll
have the option I can keep going if I wa
I did do it I just don't want to be
standing on a stage with some mustard
stain tuxedo when I'm 80 just go hey
your kid you don't understand I would
have just been this and people just we
all like sad yeah darkness I don't want
to be that guy unless I just feel like I
have to do something or I'm gonna die
but I just financially wouldn't want to
be in that position but it's just you
know with the bankers out there running
laugh loaning money that doesn't even
[ __ ] exist eventually that's gonna
topple and all you can do is just hope
it doesn't happen in your lifetime and
just keep going with the lie like hey
you give me this and I gave it I wrote
these numbers on a piece of paper so
that gets the stuff right my favorite
bill away from that bill because that
bill [ __ ] was you can't keep going
now cuz you're gonna annoy everybody
around you yeah there's no there's no
solution and all its gonna do is freak
you out and you arrive you away from
your loved ones do you think of like not
whatever it is do you think of like a
gold number in terms like if I have that
then I'm definitely set for you know for
not working but do you think in terms
like that just now starting to think as
far as like you know I mean I've been
really frugal
I mean I haven't blown any money but you
know they you know but now I think if
somebody like and not that I know you
real well but I think of like stranger
were to hang out with you they would
never guess that you're as successful as
you are you tanks
oh it's not a compliment
they would thank you just some [ __ ]
guy how much you love the pretzel rods I
mean you just don't seem like the
reserve chute the first one didn't know
it just you're gonna bounce there so
you're so successful and I'm saying that
like you're modest man that's all I'm
saying
the hero you know you know you're not a
big look Harley sing I like you'll drive
fancy cars you like your truck 68 f100 I
redid the whole [ __ ] thing shifts
three and retreats what's this [ __ ] yeah
that's not a little fancy a little flair
Jesus I'm kidding I don't ya know I
think I think it's you're also sitting
in the nosebleed sections and stadiums
when you could probably get a box you
could get a [ __ ] field pass most
overrated thing ever I agree with the
box I don't like the box
Wow I will not be inviting you guys to
Brad in my pocket food oh [ __ ] I don't
you don't feel the energy of the [ __ ]
crowd and you're just in like this this
poor excuse no [ __ ] living room and
then like when the game and people are
talking and active trying to like making
deals and [ __ ] the mono 80% of the
[ __ ] people in there that's the worst
part of the box that's the worst part if
you could have your own box and you
dictate who's in there with you it
changes but when you're like you're at
the game your guys like guys that got
the ticket from somebody and oh I work
at this [ __ ] financial can't walk in
closet separate entrance
don't the wings stink yeah and the
horking concierge service how mr. Christ
sure how are you doing today
let's hope the Rams win oh I can [ __ ]
go for me I think about just like you
know you can do that at home with your
flat-screen TV I know dude you can do
what's great about watching the game at
home if that's what you want to do yeah
okay
the
at my things if I'm going to the game I
want to be with [ __ ] real fans we I
want to be pretty buzzed I want the game
to be a [ __ ] big game I'm gonna see
some future hall-of-famers this game
means something I'll go to that game but
then other than that it's just I'd
rather be sitting at home with some
friends we can eat whatever we want we
can drink whatever we work for as long
as we want there's nobody there's no
lines no lines to the [ __ ] bathroom
nobody standing up in front of you none
of that [ __ ] we we went to the get down
like Kaepernick during the [ __ ] with
national anthem you don't get up you're
home right yeah we went to the RAM for
season tickets to the Rams and we went
to the Rams game this weekend my kids my
wife we're like we're staying until the
end we want to watch them win and I was
like I was like I don't think you guys
have ever been to assist 90,000 people
in here right now and when they're all
gonna get off into Vermont Ave we were
in the parking garage for an hour the
parking garage wasn't moving
it was like insane I was like oh no if
you if you don't if you don't leave yeah
you just stay you just finds it don't
you spy the grill back up again I said
to them I go I go how about we just
[ __ ] just rakes it savage who'd you be
your celebrity best friend probably
Angelina now we want you know I think
you'd be great I'd like a vial of his
blood around her neck just like totally
got into Tom Tom what is it about you
bill I told you you got no swag I can't
when you carry even when you don't
chicks respond its to 5 it was 2.5
sweeten the pot a little 10-minute guest
by the [ __ ] pool house I think the
best wouldn't like a boxer who also does
Co promotion you know I mean like the
who your best you know do you know you
connect with Bernard Hopkins know who
Mel Gibson thanks you and Mel Gibson
like you kids you listen I hope you like
just stir them up yeah Mel Gibson love
Mel Gibson dude if if every one of us
here got forgot like our whole [ __ ]
persona got defined by the voice message
we left when some chick was breaking up
with us I'm not saying we would use all
the words he used but that's not gonna
be the best you know yeah and I think
people are way more complex than that
I'm not saying the guy doesn't got a few
issues here there but right but
everybody does you know what I mean even
liberals you're so empathetic man huh
you have so much empathy because I Know
Who I am and I [ __ ] up tremendously in
life so every time I start to really
harshly judge somebody there's that
[ __ ] voice and back ahead but bill
remember you did this yeah yeah you did
this yeah why don't you shut the [ __ ] up
take your hat out of the ring put it
back on your dumb head no Gibson gonna
be fun as [ __ ] down in Malibu especially
the great filmmakers of all time he's
amazing look that was the [ __ ]
Apocalypto was one of the best songs
ever that is true one of the best movies
I've ever seen you know I just feel like
I don't know whatever YouTube must have
seen that I'm into Mel Gibson and so it
just started suggesting Apocalypto clips
and I just started watching it through
YouTube the other day again [ __ ] up
those phenomena those [ __ ] Fernet
highly underrated man like it's not
talked about that off and I'd never
what's the one he's making right now
he's got a movie coming out yeah it's
movie yeah hacksaw bridge or something I
think
how's that not gonna be good even that
gringo one was good remember the one
we're using that Mexican prison came out
like a year or two ago you're selling
well it was really good not like on the
level of pop though but really good
movie I see that yeah oh it's really
really good he's in this Mexican prison
he's like the one American there it's a
WoW
it's [ __ ] really cool movie yeah he's
a yeah I always I'm always shocked when
I see like people people throw rocks in
a glass house like people go how dare he
I always go whoop what life did you live
that you know you're not afraid of
anyone my buddy works great
now people just chime in and hey I went
to school with you 20 years ago when you
did this yes sorry I'd like to withdraw
from the race Oh campaign is over yeah
being the person that [ __ ] like like
I I when I'm doing stand-up and I'm just
[ __ ] around cuz I always look at it
like I'm joking and I always [ __ ] on
myself too but legitimately go on like a
serious show and take someone to task
that you never met you know you know
that's that's a tough one man like like
you'd have to have lived an incredible
life yeah to to pull that off I've yet
to like I think right now my Karma like
if I was to die today like that that'd
be a pick'em whether I was gonna go
north the south at the end of this
probably wouldn't be I probably probably
getting a few points I'd be like a minus
a plus six dog I was like when you run
into someone and they tell you what's
your point spread having a hell you
favorite you an underdog even I got some
yeah I'm probably I'm doing some time
apart Tory dude you left a championship
football game to go home to not be
appreciated by the people that you came
therefore another that to me that's a
pick six momentum changer in the game
yeah okay man I see it so differently
but good go how do you see it just what
a piece of [ __ ] he is for leaving that
game his alma mater his friends were
there one of the great national
championship games of all time I think
Jesus would reject you wholeheartedly I
think I look at it the same way I just
brought up some great points I look at
it the same way that who's the you
kicked a field goal who's the guy I
don't think of it goes that goes [ __ ] it
you know what it's all about the story
like I watching that game live is
equally a great memory okay I saw what I
saw if if you come back and beat Florida
and we storm the field of Florida State
one of the best games I've ever been to
but the story for me of being the idiot
that comes in and my wife hands me a
beer and goes you're gonna need this
true that's true those those stories got
a better life experience it's not a
better life experience the better story
is never the better life experience
anything about this [ __ ]
yeah private island yeah I could do it
it can be done these islands to be
bought you can get one the Bahamas I
think no yeah I'm well the Bahamas
Thursday no they have like you know what
are you gonna do out there going on a
cruisee though in the isle of island of
dr. Moreau just gonna slowly go crazy
yeah
become like 400 pounds have your face
painted no I'm gonna I want to own a bar
that is the like the majority the eating
is in the sand it's covered by a Hut
it's next to like a whenever like a
passport control so everyone's gotta
stop in on my island and go to there to
clear the pasture it open the British to
the American Virgin Islands and then I'm
sitting right there and they come by and
they're like you're the ribs over there
[ __ ] a minute he makes three things
he makes ribs
he makes french fries and he makes hot
wings and they're cute and he makes
friends and he makes friends Christ your
island crazy oh I love your society 2.0
fine agitation bugs mouth like a fantasy
someone was talking the other day about
reading books I don't know no I daydream
and like mean I literally did that today
I was sitting in here I cleaned that man
camps I know you guys coming over and I
sat in I was daydreaming about like the
silliest stuff like just like I would go
daydream for daydream with you what do
you got oh I can't it's so silly I can
tell you my dream yesterday yeah is that
I show up to the Stanhope taping and
Johnny Depp comes up to me and it's like
he's like yeah I listen to podcast you
talk you're absolutely hilarious if you
ever want to just hang out like you
should hang out in just a manga tars
I'd be like oh cool and then Doug would
go hey did you talk to Johnny Depp I was
like I did he was like he's talked about
the guitars like oh yeah
Doug's like let's just all bail on this
and go back to Snape to the depths all
pedestrian so far okay see I would have
taken it to the point that I went and I
played the guitar and was so
unbelievable and Joe Perry just happened
to be there
right next to now I'm jamming with
Aerosmith yeah I'm singing backups
that's real why the way I'm with Joey
Kraemer does some great on drums somehow
I shape-shift and now I'm playing the
drums cuz that's the cool part whenever
I listen to a [ __ ] song whatever the
best part of the song is in that moment
I'm doing it every [ __ ] song male or
female solo I'll listen to wreath of
Franklyn just think that I had a cartoon
voice like Mel Blanc and I could sing
like that for a character on my show I
think [ __ ] like that when I'm [ __ ]
walking around oh I talk I think about
that with with like singing like R&B and
soul singing like things like aretha
like I saw Brian McKnight stuff like
terrorism single-handedly my god do
everything about rescuing like school
buses full of kids I think that'll be my
big oh my gosh shucks after you do it
and Oprah wants an interview but you
turn her down because that's not why you
did it
oh yeah that was the first 20 minutes of
me walking my dog today you gotta be a
dreamer man what the [ __ ] else you gonna
do yeah I think about that [ __ ] all the
time about like I'll get on a plane and
I'll be like Who am I rescuing first
yeah this goes down and I remember
thinking having plane rescue fantasies
all the time oh all the time especially
if I see one of them walk on board then
I really start to fantasize absolutely
yep yeah I get there the worst no do you
start to like fantasize about like about
taking a weapon out of their hand
oh I've fantasized about that having a
throat that's not our focus we grew up
on all those action moves that's true
yeah well blame them yeah it all seemed
believable do you think do you think I
wish we had the UH period we're like
homeless guys were breaking in to the
houses around here and I I like did my
scenario like of how to take a gun out
of someone's hand the way to knock it
sure like hit their hand hit the gun but
you got to do it work to the open part
of their hand and you take it away and
then take it from them put it right back
in her face caught serial killers and
rescue people that were down in a pit Oh
in the house yeah have you ever loved
gunshots and I've walked out like it was
nothing that was
most amazing bravery we've ever seen now
just and I still made it to my gig just
bandaged myself up do you ever fantasize
about saving your okay so guy breaks
into my house bunch of young kids break
into my house they don't know I'm there
when I come in
of course if they did I do I do want to
avoid legsweep like this one guy
standing back to me I kick his feet and
he hits the ground right yeah I then
disarmed the other two I get them down
there apologizing just let us go sir and
my line to them is I'm gonna have fun
with you guys I was gonna say you gotta
have a catchphrase oh and then this is
gonna take a while and I'm gonna torture
them I on a box like in Game of Thrones
that's that's on the movie poster yeah
this is gonna take a while they get
single Wow good torch especially rescue
torture fantasies you know the flip side
of that is I always start to do that
then I was like I can't do that because
then anybody come now you have to just
put a bullet in somebody's [ __ ] it I
couldn't like oh I couldn't listen to
the screaming that's that's why I get
out of the fantasy I got I don't want to
do that yeah I'll just [ __ ] it just
give me one right I guess I was walking
iliyan I was Lee Ann's like go check the
backyard make sure the what you'll call
turn the trash cans are in but it's real
hard to get around because everything's
closed off so I gotta come around you
gotta kind of like doing in specialist I
have a flashlight that's also a stun gun
and I'm going around to buy that off
Bobby Kelly semi-automatic [ __ ]
flashlight they got a hat that's got a
weight a little weight in it so you take
it off and you hit someone with it I got
a bunch of [ __ ] I got a gun that shoots
around that extra weight on your head
compressing your neck that's what you
kind of you gotta be hoping what [ __ ] I
want to use it right I fantasize about
which way to Ventura what do you say
about
fantasize about running down the stairs
at an intruder for a little to have that
momentum
last that's that's Indiana Jones but big
ball of rock chasing someone
like somebody breaks in and I hear it
from bed and I pop up and I run down the
stairs and meet them at but with the
momentum of running down the stairs I
who he thinks the biggest psycho here
the three of us I'm gonna go you I'm
going Tom really tom tom has a look in
his right now he's looking at me with it
he's got a look in his [ __ ] eye like
Tom like all Tom needs is a couple of
[ __ ] left and right turns the right
scenario needs to present itself and the
damage that this man could do I think I
I think I would choose myself really
yeah because I do kind I mean I would
like to like really in measured way that
he talks yeah - really really violently
justifiably hurt somebody give me a hand
elector where they said his heart rate
wouldn't go up or down
yeah he just stayed the same that's this
guy oh I'm a lot of screaming talking
[ __ ] trying to get you to stop me like
trying to I'm a lot of big like big
throat like even when I got in fights in
college I was the guy to talk so much
[ __ ] but then the second they said let's
take it outside I'd be like someone
getting the [ __ ] out of here like I
remember I remember really
I said well you had some people weren't
really wanting to hurt you know I used
to do that all the time Joe DeRosa
nobody died no I've never seen him back
down to anybody the amount of fit back
in the day when he was a younger man
right now he's cooled but back when he
was in New York I never saw a guy talk
more [ __ ] while backing up in a bar and
what would happen was he would back up
and then everybody else would get in the
middle and it was just the Mantovani
[ __ ] guys I saw that guy talk [ __ ]
dude I'm really yeah what the one time
we were on the street this [ __ ] crazy
homeless guy he's like just Joe just say
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] this guy was icon
do that and I was just like afterwards
like when I was like kind of pissed at
him we got to the project chill and they
totally disarmed me by just owning up to
it [ __ ] yeah I know the riot I get in my
ego I'm like joke that guy would have
beat you to death with me yeah I know
you're right
did you get in a lot of fights I got up
to
outside of my family right up until
about like junior high cuz I stayed back
in first grade I had a lot of baby fat
so like I was in a decent weight class
so I did alright
and then once kids started hitting like
you know there's always the kid with the
mustache in sixth grade once all of a
sudden like there was somebody like six
inches taller than you like I had to I
had to humble myself I lost I lost to
this kid we planed street hockey and I
just got mad he kept these [ __ ]
battery played hockey and I just was
just all [ __ ] emotion out there and I
turned around to square off and I
remember him looking at me like really
and I just was like before I always
thinking you know I was throwing like
you know you know people do the the the
stand-up it's about women fighting what
they just thought about those women
flailing your arms that's what I did and
he just sort of just just Mayweather to
all of them and the decide got me with
like three really and I left crying it
was bad like I wanted to say I was like
six or seventh grade I was in junior
high I was trying to fight off the cry
like an animal not it happens he just
his ass just laying right in a shirt
it's alright
yeah I got I got well ago Segura though
I don't know who do you think would be
the first person to get into a fight on
the street due to traffic us three yeah
never me never made me do it I have not
had a physical confrontation since I
can't even remember I can show you with
the most rage though maybe I'm
definitely just because you're angry
doesn't mean you're gonna win I'm and I
just saw I saw enough [ __ ] growing up
that I was just like I don't want that
to happen to me like enough violence oh
yeah like just like I mean it's just
some we're in junior high all of a
sudden kids got over a hundred pounds
and they got coordinated and I saw with
the the end result of being on the
bottom and there was no teachers there
oh yes scary yeah there was a kid who
dude this kid was just a man-child
[ __ ] shredded kid and he fought this
other dude who was kind of a big baby he
we could but I wasn't there but this kid
didn't come to school for like a week
and he came back and he still didn't
look like himself this kid proved he got
off the bus first and the kid
pushed him jumped on his chest and just
started [ __ ] you know those extra
nine punches you get in UFC for some
reason after you knock somebody out the
only thing I like about the sport
dealing with the bottom of your fist
after you just [ __ ] he's doing that
with his arms
you still get three more hammer fists
yeah he was doing that and there was
nobody there
it was one of those fights I imagine the
crowd sound like this like yeah he
didn't come to school for a [ __ ] week
and the swelling was still like
noticeable I like you say that the faded
black and blue marks like dude that kid
his it looked like both his eyes were
closed and I was just like yeah we had
another kid hit another kid in the face
of the bodily of this giant scar another
kid in his college years was in a fight
gotta top this guy bit the guy's ear and
the guy pulled away any bit part of his
[ __ ] ear off all like that dude that
was just like it was just it was just
beyond and then there was always that
kid who got knocked down he was on the
ground and then that kid you didn't even
know was in the fight came over and
boots him in the head you know that's
funny um that's the sound of a
Timberland hitting somebody's head is
just it's a nauseating sound yeah I
didn't have that in me to take to that
level so I've always said if I ever went
into war I would I would be the guy
crying in the foxhole but if I could
just will myself to kill that first
person after I did then it there's a
possibility that I would be that guy
running around in his underwear with the
knife at night I always just knew that
like like you're too big of a [ __ ]
hothead that you're gonna you're gonna
get you're gonna be that guy on the
ground and you're gonna get booted in
the head and I just was not [ __ ]
worth it it was way more than that than
being like I was afraid of what I'd do
to somebody I was more afraid of like I
just don't I don't want to be that guy I
saw a guy in college knock a guy out
with one punch but well this is the we
were royal pavilions it's the guy one
punch and the guy goes back unconscious
and his head hit the
Cement uh and the look of the guy that
hit him was like I really [ __ ] up like
I remember that look going like like he
was like [ __ ] all talking [ __ ]
both in their faces and jaws this guy
and you see the guy do the starched out
arms and hits the cement and the guy
that hit him was like oh [ __ ] I didn't
mean to do that like I meant to you know
do this there's a video on YouTube this
kid he like it's like seventh graders
cake just caught him the right way in
the gym and the kid fell right back hit
his head went into a coma never woke up
and [ __ ] died and if you look at it
the other kid starts to fight this kid
squares off knocks him out one punch and
then just walked away just basically
defended himself and this the kid
[ __ ] died Jesus man and he's like a
seventh graders got to deal with that
yeah that's the rest of your [ __ ]
life yeah that's [ __ ] I'm glad
there's certain things I'm glad I'm glad
I never like really beat the [ __ ] out of
anybody yeah I got beat up a couple
times but every time I don't like we
have all those hero fantasies yeah cuz
you still question it if it happened or
what I do past the seventh grade yeah do
I have do I have it in me all right so
you couldn't beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody with your hands could you shoot
someone no but some reason shooting
seems especially the bigger the distance
yeah it just seems like you know you're
right okay I could I could sniper
someone before I could shoot them
meaning like if you put me on top of a
building like I was just watching
American sniper today yeah if you put me
on top of a building and I had to
protect my friends by shooting a woman
with a grenade in your hand I could
probably do that before I could what's
the biggest thing you could kill biggest
thing yeah
kangaroo I couldn't kill a whale can't
kill a whale can't kill an elephant no
no no one of the great cat Tigers cats
can't kill one of those either
I killed us I killed a rat in our
backyard couldn't kill a bear no [ __ ]
way
no not even to eat it well bear honey
your die I I'm very I'm sure if
that's not what bear hunting is I think
I saw bear hunting on TV and it's almost
like they bait it like they go here's a
jar of honey but you know like they put
a feel for it and then they sit in a
tent and then the bear goes and gets it
they shoot the bear when it no that's
I'm sure that's not what I saw on TV I
will say this Joe Rogan gave me some of
his elk meat yeah oh my god I made chili
out of it and I made these burgers
burgers were [ __ ] phenomenal there's
this recipe on on the internet I found
that was like you put Swiss cheese on it
then a fresh slice of prosciutto
dude it was [ __ ] real easy I'll eat
the [ __ ] out of that I don't think I
could shoot I couldn't any of those
animals and should we do so because I
know I know exactly genocide I'll live
in the country yes right yeah I wouldn't
do it right lean the mallet guys yes
absolutely I don't want to keep killing
it basic white guys we did we killed a
buffalo for trip flip and wrote and went
up to this plane we were on an Indian
Reservation you know our whole thing was
if you're cool with eating it you better
be cool with the harvest that's what
they kept saying was so they get up
beside it slow real [ __ ] yeah that's the
real [ __ ] right there because you know I
could kill a chicken corn killer duck I
could kill a chicken I couldn't kill a
duck I could kill a and I could kill I
didn't think I could do it but I could
kill like a steer I could do it cuz I
saw a guy one time do it on TV and I was
like oh my god that's terrible to watch
yeah the thing kept [ __ ] bumping into
all the other cows and [ __ ] him up so
he [ __ ] you know they just sort of
penned the thing off so it wouldn't be
stress and make the meat taste [ __ ] up
he shoots the thing and then they tied
like this rope around the things back
legs and they had like a [ __ ] wasted
up
yeah host it up and then they got the
thing I'm like oh my god this is
terrible is gross he peels the skin off
it's disgusting lobster head off and all
that type of [ __ ] but then when he got
down and he started cutting out the
steaks my mouth started on the head the
skin and everything is gone you start
the [ __ ] becomes familiar like oh my god
it's a t-bone right
is the filet I kill Pig I think but pigs
I guess it kind of cool
I'm stop the pig in the heart huh I
stopped to pick in the heart really yeah
yeah honey pigs we to kill it
I think dogs are getting charged that's
wrong so getting mauled is damaged or
hold the pig down the pigs making real
raping noises like holding him down hold
him down like the all the dogs with big
Hawaiian pitbulls
hold them down by the ears but biting
onto the pigs ears biting onto its legs
by known as [ __ ] just holding it down
he's like eight dogs and then they give
you a salt like a knife and they're like
stout at the heart runner it's armed
this guy went in stabbed it I want to in
stab that we all stabbed it because you
know we want to beat you miss did you do
it or what I think we all missed I think
they ended up stabbing it and killing it
it was so [ __ ] stressful any time
every time that you do that you're like
ah [ __ ] man I don't I'm not a hunter
I'll have this [ __ ] mammy I'd have
been a mark or gather just outlet woods
daydreaming I kind of like him berries
and I also like making bringing these
back to the cave be cool you know you
just sort of like you know put it on the
end of a stick maybe guys if you heat up
these berries the sugars start really
kind of popping they all have that gold
[ __ ] you know the tribal tattoo they
got the warrior thing on they're just
sitting there wearing like a [ __ ] I
know smock because if we smear the
berries on the outside of the pig
they'll caramelize I bet it'll be pretty
good candy you have no ascertainable
skills in an apocalypse no [ __ ]
survival know anything that's great you
want to be the first wave that dies you
don't want to be you want to be there
when the new government gets set up and
it's all the way back to like [ __ ]
the Trojan horses and battles and [ __ ]
no you don't that's why I had no I
wasn't worried at all when that [ __ ]
[ __ ] in North Korea was talking
about how he was gonna shoot something
over to LA I was this yeah right on my
house
I'm watching Pope of Greenwich Village
go ahead it's my favorite scene and
that's it right now that's the worst
place to be would be in [ __ ]
Bakersfield we just got a little bit of
the radiation you go walk that off it's
the people of Bakersfield [ __ ] come
up with the new laws I do a bit on that
these are the new rules
[Music]
I saw staying home special last night oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah I avoid his specials
because I want to still feel like I'm
funny man people help you some people
just make you feel like you're in the
wrong business
last night I was retainers got a big one
- what he's got a new one I heard his
Cedric yeah yeah I watched I watched the
first ten minutes last night he has the
Tennessee I think Tennessee State
marching band opened up the walk on
stage and play him on oh [ __ ] like like
what do you what's your next question
what's the concept are you gonna top
that I do with my shirt off comes out
soon right
it comes out in December or November I
think yeah I did he's shirtless that was
maybe a tactical error right before all
this fat shaming came out a special
shirtless sit on the stool at one point
my belly goes over my jeans yeah I
watched analyze the last time I saw you
you basically all you had on was a sock
yeah yeah over his junk yeah it's so
funny you texted me today and the last
picture you sent me was a sock on the
floor just by itself yeah you did give
it away now
yeah the goddamn comedy champ I'm that
was uh that was I was at their other
naked pictures of you from other oh do
you know it's funny I can't remember the
song I did that's how [ __ ] nuts it
was seeing you do that what was uh who's
me you Margaret Cho Ron White and Harlan
Williams yeah Ron white killed
give me three steps give me three really
comes out I mean he's a [ __ ] yeah
just got Robins hat remember that was
that what that was Ronnie's in Van
Zant's Widow sent Ron white Ronnie Van
sans hat to do the song it he's living
your life dude is a famous French that's
what I am in this business not for the
art but for all the [ __ ] extras like
I love the [ __ ] I love that like the
marching band coming out with me that's
something I'd be into yeah I love that
he is [ __ ] funny by the way man
that's Cedric so oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's this opening clip where he has
he has like other comics talking about
him like just real quick yeah
like Seinfeld says something it's just
like a image and then you hear him
talking about him and then Chris Rock
goes the hardest gig I've ever had was
following Cedric the Entertainer New
Year's Eve in Oakland following him
that's already tough yeah New Year's Eve
impossible Oakland all over my burn eMac
is still my favorite out of the Kings of
Comedy yeah Bernie Mac was that [ __ ]
set I scared you [ __ ]
what's the hardest unbelievable hardest
follow you ever had like a like a whole
[ __ ] this is a total nightmare a follow
scenario like following someone like you
want to go I'll I'll say I'll go way
back in the day all right I would say
read Johnny and the round guy oh wow
read Johnny at the Boston Comedy Club
they used to end doing that doing uh
talking about going to the club yeah and
then they would start doing that song it
takes two it takes two to make a thing
go right and one of them was beatbox in
the other one was singing that it takes
you to make it out of sight and they we
flipping the lights of the club on and
off and they would be dancing up there
you know that [ __ ] wasn't in the strobe
thing where you missed all like the guys
over here and then he's over here they
do that and if you were a new comic Matt
Frost and Jason Steinberg were running
the club they would put you on then your
first time there to see what would
happen to see if you if you could oh oh
my god oh my god
did like it was just like it was like I
wasn't even on stage and the show was
[ __ ] over if they weren't looking
at me you know I mean they must have
just been talking amongst themselves
there's very few people that Matt Dane
Cook past that went up and murdered
after him really murdered [ __ ] Martin
then career Barnes Greer Barnes is
another one Greer Barnes was a monster
on stage I haven't seen him forever
ah is he still doing stand-up yeah where
is he is MIA I mean he's [ __ ] like
he's one of the peas one of the best
have you ever seen Greer Barnes he would
do this scuba diving bit he'd stopped
talking be underwater and he would stop
talking he's just imitating with making
the bubble noises he's gesturing and all
this stuff murdering murdering I just
remember the end he would shoot the guy
yes peg was cuz I'm from the Bronx and
the place would go nuts one of the best
beatbox guys ever I mean was just a
total [ __ ] entertainer yeah and then
you would go up when I always hated was
even the white people were disappointed
and I want to be a [ __ ] white - yeah
this is what we are [ __ ] you I'm a
monologist Oh settle down I do my
political humor I was up there in a
tweed jacket some [ __ ] from the paper
chase after his [ __ ] act
Jeremy Hawks Jeremy hots guts on a
[ __ ] roll yeah I'm just gonna name
guys cuz it's always like the same like
obviously rogue and all really Dave
Attell all of those guys everybody knows
but these these other [ __ ] guys
Jeremy Hearts could do would you
wouldn't even say a setup premise he
just go I went to Ikea and once they get
a death in that rhythm with piece of
[ __ ] that is once they buy into that
[ __ ] thing they'll laughing before he
gets to it and then what I love is is
the punchline is worthy of how hard
they're already laughing but even more
Sony that keeps going and going and
going and going and going that guy Tony
woods oh not a brutal one you know
laughter oh my god last year is I keeps
was blah blah see if you talk of my
favorite tires he's still doing it yeah
this is he worked out at the aquarium
that's what you're saying Tony woods
Tony woods if I don't see him then
they're not in the business you really
you really got a problem Tony woods and
I had the best moment on stage I'm in
the DC Improv Sunday show sold out I'm
towards the end of my set feeling really
good shirt off I'm retired now so I've
had a couple cocktails meeting like my
nights my body shows about over and I
hear Tony woods voice in the back tell
that story about Tracy Morgan and I go
okay I go wait who is that all sudden he
pops out of the side of the stage he
goes I was there too and I remember it
differently and then Tony woods and I
get to Mike's and tell the Tracy because
he was there that night and tell the
Tracy Morgan story and I would tell mine
and then Tony would discount everything
I said and I was like Burt was [ __ ] up
he was the first person to take his
shirt off and it just I said I say
shorty
it was it was the greatest funny moment
and hands there right LeAnn's in the
back of the room I got my camera I got
it it is do you have that on tape I get
offstage I go please tell me you
recorded that LeAnn goes I should have
right how are you [ __ ] kidding me she
goes that was I was magic I was just was
lost Tony was just good to just have the
story though that's true
Tony woods had told the story so much
better the only thing we really have in
common that story is the ending is that
that's how you get out of paying the
check yeah but Tony tells it so
differently it's so much better because
I'm gonna say it to Jay or how does it
end
yeah was Jay more there that night yes
Tony got pissed and called me one night
a little buzz and he goes the [ __ ] gene
we're telling our story for and I was
like oh no I was like that's long he's
like [ __ ] hey and she didn't have it
in I was like I know yeah I know it's
I'm sorry Tony Tony was it but Tony best
impressions in the business stuff
he really thought you really does tell
do some [ __ ] amazing impressions who
really does he's the best I ever saw
haven't said that haven't said that yeah
it's your story yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he but man Tony wood tells that
story and I told him I was like you
should start telling that story because
it the way Tony Tony so good at telling
story he takes a little nuance and then
adds it but he just [ __ ] sprinkles
and hammer a hammer things yeah and he
just know he's just laid back
I said come up with the bill dude he
kills like a guy screaming and sweating
and he's just like just talking we did a
shoreline amphitheater last year yeah
Chappelle's headlining Tony goes like
fourth to last he does a set like that
just like yeah so I've said like talking
like that yeah
standing ovations from 20,000 people and
then the three of us that are after him
are like this is gonna [ __ ] suck yeah
he just I mean he murdered murdered the
place drawers destroyed so hard Tommy
Hitman Hearns story he has to play Tommy
Hearns yes like Danny saw that yeah body
type yeah I mean I spent I spent I spent
a solid I'd say there is no Duran movie
Kansas Stone they should have had cuz
Tommy Hearns [ __ ] knocked him out
Tommy Hearns knocked out Roberto Duran
all I want to say was the left hook it
was [ __ ] because he was like 6 1 but
could make weight it like 160 yeah crazy
size was the one with the dreadlock or
tho jheri curl jheri curl when he fought
Hagler yeah yeah oh [ __ ] those were good
that was boxing with bars I always
always [ __ ] bet on him and and he
would he would [ __ ] have fights won
but he was such a fighter he never like
ran away or anything in the end he just
was just still stand there going toe to
toe in the amount of times he just end
up getting caught or just get out
pointed it still bugs me that they gave
that to Sugar Ray against Hagler yeah I
think that Hagler won that fight and
Sugar Ray the last 10 seconds and would
steal the [ __ ] round
yeah do you think you think boxing will
go away one day
uh yeah I think it's all gonna be taken
over by robots I think eventually well
eventually they got they have him at
this point what people can [ __ ] him
right and they try to get it down that's
another bit I never should've stopped
doing just like talking about some guy
he's [ __ ] this robot but he's wearing
like the lab coat so he still feels like
he's doing research
just bang other people standing there
watching them [ __ ] clipboards there's
something on the [ __ ] doesn't quite
feel like a [ __ ] but the rest of it is
awesome Oh it'll go away from our
country what's that boxing everything
we'll leave here first just be able to
you'll be able to see all this you'll
have to go to Mexico there's too much
money to be made I feel but but once if
there was ever a major like class-action
suit where they really had to pay people
out other than what the [ __ ] NFL did
which they basically gave everybody like
five grand yeah collectively yeah you
know I think football would go away
first cuz everyone cuz just not because
the NFL gives a [ __ ]
it's just because so many of my friends
that have kids now the kids are playing
soccer really yeah because they don't
want they don't want you the thing about
it is dudes the odds of making it into
the NFL all right a so [ __ ]
astronomical and then you're gonna sit
there watching your third grade kid
going out there and just get knocked
around my dad took me out of football in
third grade
really he saw it for what it was my dad
didn't want me to play football I played
two years went with JV seventh grade
moved up to varsity in eighth grade and
my dad was like this is a [ __ ] bad
idea and I was like I love it I love the
idea of getting marks on your helmet
head to head I was like oh like a
[ __ ] idiot and then baseball just a
to paintball governor football you could
do self esteem combined with your need
to let to be liked yeah yeah that is a
deadly combination
in football yeah because you be who has
to be a wedge breaker I'll do it
they think I'm crazy oh you'd love it
and then when the smoke cleared and your
brain was mush none of those [ __ ]
people would call you dude my I got it
that guy back injury mowing the lawn you
know Gatorade football went to the
hospital and my dad was like you're
gonna practice on Monday really yeah you
see that no and you can see it in his
eyes that's exactly how his dad said it
and now you got what this in front of
you yeah Emily your son play football a
hundred percent really quite a percent
I've been like I've never I would never
do like you got to play a sport but as
far as like I highly suggest that you
yeah if you want me to love you that
kind of stuff yeah my father loved me if
you want me to love you the way my
father loved me I mean he's got some toy
footballs now we're playing see hon that
had those water moccasin absolutely then
taught me how to turn fear in the anger
oh there's an early football stuff
there's no there's no there's I don't
even know if you can raise a kid like we
were raised that's illegal
I think it's coming back you think I
think bullying is gonna come back in a
big way always corny yeah and then 20
years before yeah like like in the 80's
disco stunk and then in the 90s all of a
sudden somebody started playing the Bee
Gees again right just like oh man I
remember this my mom used to play this
in the car like bullying's gonna come
back man like we're gonna go too far
with the kales already out right right
people have moved on from yoga into
Pilates it's all gonna come back to
Gold's Gym again push it up no pain no
gain
it's gonna go back I'll spit slowly
moving that back cuz you got accountants
do it [ __ ] walking out of squats is
the most narcissistic [ __ ] work and
we get it you're working out why do you
have the garage door open they're
running down the street yeah look at us
we're working out running bye-bye froyos
just jogging I prospect right now
[ __ ] I love it I love it
the thing that sucks is they do they
don't they make all the plates the same
size right so the tens
what's forty five points and like all
that [ __ ] is short-term [ __ ] you're
gonna get [ __ ] shredded you're gonna
look great but the wear and tear and
only move my arm is high right now
yeah cuz that [ __ ] your shoulders
ache a shoulder I [ __ ] my shoulder and
we're all so old yeah yeah you can't you
can't once you get over 40 dude you
can't like you absolutely need jerks the
[ __ ] am i doing to clean enjoy oh I put
a gym in my house and I went out and I
got weight so I can I can try to put up
to most ever put up I did it one time I
put up to 25 which is the two plates on
both sides but I did it one time Ron
what I'm better years ago yeah I did it
one time something like I'm gonna get
[ __ ] back to that right and I start
getting up to 155 and I'm feeling my
shoulder and I'm you know 80s kid
pushing through it put that do it got up
to 175 for three [ __ ] reps and the
next day dude I felt like I threw like
[ __ ] from the warning track a thousand
times and I just now that neither
humbled that I am when I walk into my
gym and I see all of this [ __ ] weight
like this dust on the 45 I keep trying
to dust it off so people come in just
thinking like why you keep a really neat
gym yeah it's like I just kind of use
the elliptical I use the speed bag a
little bit and then like other than that
I do push-ups I'm into like body weight
like pull-ups and I bought these things
he atomic weights they look like little
cannonballs and you're kind of like
that's the [ __ ] that itthat's a kind of
strength that I think doesn't really
[ __ ] with your body and it's something
that you should be able to do because I
always think like you know if I'm on the
road I'm in a hotel fire like how would
I get out you know whenever I watched
Cirque de Soleil I'm like this not a
floor high enough that you could put
these people that they couldn't somehow
climb down oh yeah the three-story jump
into a air bag like I could totally
[ __ ] jump myself into a pool really
oh yeah I did I did a three so it's not
an air bag and there's there's no real
good deep ends in hotels anymore most of
it is just like five feet all the way
across because of lawsuits once they got
rid of the diving boards which I also
think are going to come back yeah diving
boards are never coming but I got to
come back you think it got to the 1970s
diving but what's a diving board they're
really cool
that's a major problem with the
toughness of kids today is they don't
know what it feels like to wipeout on a
diving board you get that that diving
board rash on your legs and then you hit
the pool in the chlorine hits it you
hear everybody laughing and you're
trying to get your [ __ ] together under
the water cuz the chick you like is
sitting there and you know you're gonna
come up with your land you ever try to
do a back dive and land on your back
just everything that my kids don't know
that chin trying to do a like a just
jump up and turn and go backwards landed
on the diving board change first time
you invite the [ __ ] the dog in
realize it's gonna be swimming up to you
[Music]
[Laughter]
poison ivy and she just puts it on there
anywhere just puts that pink [ __ ] on you
dog can stand oh I [ __ ] love you dog
oh she's uh she's [ __ ] she's well
worth all the money we spent on her to
get that leg those legs fixed oh they
hit [ __ ] there when those homeless
people tried to break him and you have
130 pound dog just going hard like going
after them
there's a [ __ ] that's like having a
big dick Priscilla just scared the [ __ ]
out of people and then and then just
that that's it yeah boy and then once
the word comes out from the homeless
people like hey don't go they have a big
dog yeah that's all you need all you
need to do is just make it more of a
problem than the person next to you it's
the same thing with bullying all you had
to do was put up enough of a fight and
then it moves down to the next kid yeah
trickle down bully economics that's
right which gets you ready for the
finance world yeah so I think what we
just figured out there without any
research
is that the upsides of bullying need to
come back the thing that's gonna suck
about this podcast is that everyone's
gonna go that you had that in you this
whole time you could have been doing
these good of podcasts there's no way
I'm gonna do a better one than this
Cueto if they never got rid of bullying
I think we would we would have got a
sama way quicker with that we would have
got a sama bin Laden a lot quicker you
think oh yeah how so I'm gonna have
these politically correct troops over
there you know yeah oh yeah you guys
want to jump on this now you guys
actually listen to me like this is
actually true I'm just being absurd
that's one of those classic things that
they just take a clip of it the podcast
the next thing you know you're on the
front page of The Daily Mail not support
the troops be honest honest frugal
comedian bill burr does not support the
troops nine-year-old Prius no no no
bigger friend paid off paid off yeah
yeah really yeah you pay off everything
yes I do I don't do well with debt
I don't like owing people [ __ ] and I
don't like yeah I don't like working for
other people assume that capacitance
when you get a paycheck what do you do
it you put it in savings do you invest
it I do a little bit of a bunch of [ __ ]
but I but it's all very conservative and
now I got to the point I paid my house
down and everything so now I want to buy
a modest house down paid it off paid it
off paid it up
[ __ ] yeah we just borrowed against what
our house to do this what do you want to
buy I thought you said you're about to
say it's gonna buy like a small rental
unit learn the game in something that I
can I can handle if it gets [ __ ] up
yeah and then once I learned the game
then like that's that's real estate my
my out of this business I want by the
time 70 have a couple of rental
properties that are paid off I'll live
off whatever the government lets me keep
at that point yeah I'll have my slippers
you know a couple of cigars you know
Miller High Life ice-cold yeah you know
some top-shelf booze and I'm going
anything else I got leftover I'll spend
on my wife because she's a [ __ ]
so first like a great first drink my
whole life though I am though you're so
good I think if you don't get sober by
my age you're in it you're going Peter
O'Toole oh yeah you can doing summer
stock you're going to be half in the
back
you're gonna be a sword hanging off your
belt
some people just going how does he
remember those lines did you ever call
your dad and ask him for financial
advice no my dad's an artist what my dad
is an artist at heart
so so he's not the financial no but what
I got for my dad and my mother was was
passion they're passionate people like
they love stuff they'd like I got a drug
I got that drum kit I brought out yeah
that night that love would that I had
the bottom green sparkle like I [ __ ]
love that thing to death right yeah so I
still have a drum kit at my parents
house so at this point I'm like I I
don't I barely have room for that thing
really okay so I told my parents that I
wanted to sell the other one that I have
have this old Slingerland kit and then
they just they just no but that's the
one you played like they're really
sentimental like that they're not into
the whole like well absolutely you could
take that money and then turn it into
this and be like Oh blah blah blah like
they they love this stuff that they have
and yeah they don't like they just don't
have that in a good way they don't have
that thing of you know this is a good
investment we'll buy this then we'll
flip this and then turn this into that
yeah and then we'll just you know take
out all this gorgeous [ __ ] and redo it
with Home Depot crap and maybe the 40
grand and then do it if they do it they
don't have that like they walk in here
all the way I'm gonna lose my shirt on
my house if I ever sold it was because I
did everything first [ __ ] class and
like dude I even went around to all they
all had like they know the door locks
with the skeleton keys they were all
painted shut I [ __ ] took like
stripped them all got it all out found a
locksmith who made a skeleton key so
they all [ __ ] workers I just thought
was cool you could lock doors and [ __ ]
yeah and this is what kills me this is
like your story coming back from the
championship game I'm the only one who
gives a [ __ ] I think it's so [ __ ]
cool yeah the old thing I go it works
away you liked it I cone like say my
wife Raqqah you realize these [ __ ]
door locks I bet that these things have
been painted over since probably the
1950s yeah or at least with the house
settling that it didn't even work you
know and and I totally get into all of
that this is place Liz's hardware out
here where you can buy all these old
fixtures and [ __ ]
I know where the door guy is downtown
then there's the tile guy and you buy
all this rescued [ __ ] and they call it
rescued [ __ ] it's basically these guys
at flipping houses and they go yeah
we're redoing the bathroom
the guys who demolish it they keep all
the [ __ ] and then they go around all
these places they sell it then [ __ ]
like me buy the house and want to have
it restored so it looks like it doesn't
have this weird vibe of it was made in
1923 oh wait was it made in 1987 or was
it two 13 2013 like I try to get it to
look you know and even if even if I redo
something I like the style of it has to
fit the [ __ ] house I don't want
delivering room to look like this
whatever your house is like this [ __ ]
Art Deco this Mediterranean art or they
call it craftsman house and then I don't
want you to walk in and all of a sudden
the kitchen looks like you're at the W
Hotel like I fight like Timmy it's it's
bizarre
Leanne we did we started tearing out the
wood in this house this house was built
in 1930 and so Kant would like that
anymore so I took a picture of it I did
like a periscope and I was like it bums
me out I smell this wood it's great what
it's beautiful wood and it's it's like
that's why all those old guitars and
everything are worth so much money and
allegedly sound better like I don't have
the ear obviously as a comedian but what
it is was it was an older wood and those
older trees don't exist so now the trees
that they cut down or they they farm
them or whatever if they grew in
themselves it's a younger wood so it's
like a white one or wood or something
like that and they just they sound
different they sound different I can't
[ __ ] tell well the reality is if you
get a great player you get him on
anything they sound amazing but the
reason why those guitars are worth so
much money a lot of it has to do with
that I think the other [ __ ] is the story
behind having them yeah the sentimental
value like dude I'm a sucker for like
I'm the kind of guy like I I just think
of like you know like I'll look at
something like an old chair or something
just think of the people that Saturn so
there's a weird thing it's some [ __ ] can
get so like I don't like buying like
like like a state jewelry that's creepy
buying somebody's dead grandmother's
brooch yeah you know what I mean but
there's a cool old [ __ ] like chair
that looks like he could smoke a cigar
in it like yeah redo it you know and
have it have that same look like and you
find like these guys that that's that
are into it and you that'll fix it like
I
but this lighter that I saw I'm a big
Humphrey Bogart fan and in The Maltese
Falcon he's got this [ __ ] die already
forget the name of it I bought one to
buy just to turn around to having this
guy fix it which was so quick I forget
what you call him but you just sort of
uh yeah yeah you just like ste just
stuck the cigarette and you just went on
this thing and it automatically was lit
and it was this little Art Deco looking
thing oh I know you're talking those
things called [ __ ] I hate doing this to
people on podcast because now it's gonna
drive them nuts [ __ ] just look up if
you go on if you go on YouTube this how
I found it cuz that's why I saw the
movie I was like what the [ __ ] is that
thing I just looked up Humphrey Bogart a
Maltese Falcon cigarette lighter and
you'll find it then you can find on eBay
and there's this guy in Michigan that I
found that redid the whole thing like
perfectly and every once in a while when
I get a really like they're really just
for cigar smokers but like yeah I'm
sorry you don't stick the cigarette in
it it has this little wand that has
Flint on it and whatever it's and it's
it's in this lighter fluid and then you
take it out it's this little thing and
you just go Shh like it's almost like
flash paper like it comes up and then
you light it it's so [ __ ] dope and
then the way you put it out is you just
stick it back in the hole and it it goes
when it goes into the oh [ __ ] whatever
the [ __ ] it stays in right I got a
google it no yeah I don't know what it
is but doesn't make sense if it was a
flame that you could stick it in and it
would go out but I guess it's not enough
oxygen in there and you just I don't
know made you got one of those no I I
found one and then I just had this guy
just do like the little mini overhaul on
it yeah I think [ __ ] worked on it
yeah and it's the [ __ ] and every once in
a while bring like a hardcore cigar guy
over there yeah because there's all
these rules for me with the smoke and
and booze alright if you're the Bud
Light guy I'm breaking out maker's mark
yeah alright if you're gonna [ __ ] if
you're a Huffer if you stick in the
whole cigar and I then get chomping on
the [ __ ] thing I'm not breaking out
the Cubans you know I'll get you like an
Aurora yeah which is still a great one
the end something like that something
legal but I'm not breaking out the
Cubans and I'm not breaking out you know
any top-level who Chuck I'll tell you
one great one that I got recently was
whiskey the yippee-ki-yay
you tried that [ __ ] Oh
do it if you have that [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
with the greatest thing in that night
when you have the kitchen light on and
the light goes through the bottle it
looks like gold
yippie-ki-yay oh it's the [ __ ] and but
it's but it's kind of like hipstery so
people really jump on it yeah but
somebody told me about it right before
everybody learned about it I bought two
[ __ ] bottles of it and I'm almost
done with the second one it's making me
a little sad really
yeah I'll try to get some more of it but
dude it's just like but that's the type
of [ __ ] but that's not the [ __ ] you get
drunk on yeah that's the stuff you drink
it neat and you just sip it and you
savor it but like what stinks is if when
you break out a bottle like that and a
guy keeps going back like he's drinking
Jack and cokes you just like dude that's
me yeah yeah because I like I like the
buzz yeah I like to I like to I like
those first two to chase me into the
corner the first two drinks to go here
we go yeah and then it hustles you into
a room a buzz I'm just getting [ __ ] up
I'll go with like I really think like
like maker's marks a little too sweet
for me
Jameson Irish whiskey I like some
Jameson is nice I don't need it I don't
like the sweet unlike any American
whiskey I like Jack Daniels Johnnie
Walker Black is like I don't I can't
[ __ ] around with scotch
you don't like scotch uh-uh and I had
some of the greatest Scotch ever in
Scotland for a tasting yeah and I could
not turn the corner on it I was like it
just tastes to medicinal for me too much
like two ns personal like to to like
it's gonna heal okay it's like medicine
yes it's a little too [ __ ] antiseptic
like I like the butteriness of Jameson I
like the softness on my tongue like it's
it's lamb is put me to sleep
you'd think we were talking about
lettuce and videos who's never drank it
would drink it member the first time
first time you ever have Scotch it
literally felt like somebody filled this
ashtray with water and you just took a
swig of wool it's like the worst taste
ever
Courvoisier first time ever had
Courvoisier like what is that it's a
number what capacity it's a cognac
cognac first time I've heard of cognac
was in Russia in Russia with that guy
Igor and you drank cognac and Russia
with a guy named Igor yeah we were
talking cool
we went to [ __ ] ballet me and him
went to the Bolshoi Ballet he say walk
this way at any point and he said and we
he's like get all the booze now cuz we
can't leave the little weirdo box so we
bought a he bought a bunch of cognac and
I was like nice and I had a glass of
warm cognac and I went oh really I was
like [ __ ] die I got I got a great one
for you as far as like I never really
[ __ ] with cognac but cognac you can
age it like I forget how much longer
wait 15 yes so yeah we were it's like
thousand dollars we were in Denver right
I was working with Jason lawhead and it
was the it was the first game of the NFL
season was that night was a Thursday
night and it was it was a year I think
after it was the Broncos had a home game
so was the one they lost was it against
Seattle that's the one they lost yeah I
think was after they lost to Seattle
yeah no but we had to be happy if they
won like how does that work could be ask
Tom I forget how that works but they
added maybe they were going against this
defending Super Bowl champion but I
would think that that would be a home
game all I noticed they were kicking off
the [ __ ] year we suffered it was the
first game of the year and so they told
us it was a speakeasy around the corner
which was obviously you don't need to
speak easy prohibition is over but that
was the vibra is very you know sort of
hard to find he had a knock on the door
we went in there so we had had a great
week I've made some good money and I was
just like I was like [ __ ] this it's the
first game you just feel like this is
gonna be an epic night right so yeah
what's the most expensive [ __ ] you got
so it was this stuff was like something
meant like the flower like Lafleur or
something like that it was like this 50
year old [ __ ] 60 year old stuff and it
was like I mean it was almost like $100
a shot right so I was just like you know
what [ __ ] it right and so there's this
kid in his 20s behind the bar and I go
hey we're gonna we're gonna do do a shot
of that stuff and he goes really I go
yeah but only if you drink it with us
and he goes on nah man I can't I go I'm
gonna get you a glass too he goes on I
can't I can't I can't do it and he was
young and whatever his name was like
Scott I was like Scott there's times in
your life when you say yes and this is
one of them right and he starts laughing
he goes alright this is such a good [ __ ]
he goes but only if I can split the shot
with everybody else because
like to other barbacks and they all
wanted to try yeah so they poured me in
Jason a shot and then they divvied his
up three ways yeah and we all click
glasses and you just sip the dude it was
[ __ ] it's like it hits your mouth and
all of these it felt like history do I
can't like the age of it I've never
tasted anything like it and then as it
went down your throat it was like your
whole body just relax like oh it was
other Kings who had been meditating it
was [ __ ] unbelievable and we just sat
there sipping that [ __ ] and like I've
never like so just took like like two
drops at a time yeah cuz I was like I
don't want this to end it's a hundred
bucks a shot right so we ended up
finishing that and we walked out like -
that was the greatest thing ever now
we'll go to the game and we hail'd like
a bicycle taxi and we sat there we had
like Bud Lights or something with this
every went back to that and we were just
going just riding over there was so
[ __ ] funny two guys in one of those
by the way that's hilarious yeah and we
just rode over to the stadium and we
came we have with you know a decent
seats you know and I immediately went
home and I ordered a bottle of it so I'm
so [ __ ] white trash when the bottle
shows up they do this thing to preserve
it where they have like this almost like
this wax they burn it around it or
something yeah stays so I didn't know
how to get the thing open and I'm trying
to figure out I didn't know how to do it
so I got this knife and I'm cutting at
it and [ __ ] and all it's starting to
flake up and when I opened it some of
the flakes went into it so it was like
this level of flakes wax on this
beautiful [ __ ] booze and I'm trying
to scoop it out and like every once in a
while after that I would drink in that
you know what it didn't taste as good
maybe someone was the [ __ ] wax that I
put in there but like it would never
taste it I was so disappointed because I
was just like if I can ship this in my
house with a good friend and they can
have that same feeling yeah like you
know half it was because you wanted to
experience it with a friend the other
half was I wanted him to leave with the
story like dude bars got the best
[ __ ] booze yeah dude it was yeah
[ __ ] accredits the best it's the best
glass of booze I've ever had
yes I'd Luiza 13 $300 glass of cognac on
our on our honeymoon he was incredible
I don't know so I'm so blacked out
Raleigh I threw up everywhere let's get
a drank it walked out of place and threw
up all over private island little Palm
Island admit it he's like I want to say
it's 1,200 bucks a night me and my dad
said he got us a deal I was like 39
bucks a night go out with his mobster
very last night Danny
any orders Louie the 15 any or 13th was
the expensive one and he yeah when we
start to drink it and I come up with the
idea that he's trying to kill me and I
just [ __ ] pound it I'm like we need
to leave and I walk out what happens you
get to a certain level a drunk and you
start catastrophizing I start I start
going I know when to pull the plug and I
know when to when to go to the mound and
go time to bring out the relief pitcher
the game's over for this yeah I don't
think you do do cuz you letting up the
walk-off winning homerun this world I
had Chris tell dude Chris now I love
cristão I'm not a big champagne guy we
at Chris tile that night and I was like
oh this is [ __ ] good dude what why I
like [ __ ] good it was like it's good
though because rappers and everybody
like that got into it I just thought
like that this strikes me is like new
money and they think it's the good [ __ ]
you know like when you don't have any
[ __ ] money yeah then you go up yeah
you like me you like the middle life
champagne of beers favorite [ __ ]
thing in the world is new money that you
enjoy a person more than someone who
just gets money this [ __ ] that they're
gonna buy old money is the most boring
boring no for sure but the best thing
ever is to do to add enough that's why
like the rap videos back in family made
videos was so fun was this [ __ ] that
those guys would spend money on yeah
like it was just so [ __ ] over-the-top
I got given I got given four beers by a
distillery in Michigan that are you
can't get you just can't get them they
make them and they're given to people
and they're
[ __ ] massively expensive like insane
and the guy came to my show
he's one of this tellers he brought me
the beers because these are for you
enjoy them but don't like ya any lies
how important they are and I was like
great and I won my town I one [ __ ]
shot
one morning always know when to pull
myself out of again I go something big
happened in my career for you something
happened and I went and I had one I took
the first step I was like oh that's one
of those things are you just guilty
being too honest yeah the amount of time
something like dude you gotta try this
is amazing and I skip it and I don't
like it I just you know cuz they're so
excited I'll be real with oh yeah
wondered what like a Yelp I got three of
them in the in them in the bank in the
garage I'll give you guys want to take
home enjoy it one night you'll love it
on Miller High Life I don't give a [ __ ]
if you want I'm talking about you can
snip them and throw them away but I'll
give them to you you can take them home
and enjoy them one night I'll give you
each one and and just be honest tell me
if you like it dude I went to I was in
Winnipeg with Rogan and we're there -
the night before a fight and Dana White
says let's go to dinner
I heard this so we go to there's like a
state guy oh yeah why don't we go to a
real high-end Steakhouse I'll give you
good best friend and we are yeah okay
know what would be a really good way
yeah yeah yeah I'll do it all the [ __ ]
you can like [ __ ] yeah yeah we go in
[Laughter]
we got a private dining room and the the
sommelier comes in and gives them and
it's like a known steakhouse for their
wine - yeah and he goes he says so
there's some well yeah he goes you don't
scare me
and he goes what do you got and the guys
like uh what do you mean he's like
what's the best [ __ ] on this menu and he
closes it and the guys like well I mean
it's pretty extensive here he's like
the best of the best so they bring in
the general manager to make sure he
knows what he's doing he's like hey just
so you know like if you're being serious
it's it's real serious what you're
talking about
yeah and he's like he's like bring us
three bottles and the guys like like
double checks he's like here's the price
on it and he's like yeah bring three
bottles of that and also bring me three
bottles of your best white so we have I
think you found your new best friend
dude oh my god Deena's right when he
fights
I don't want tickets to the fight I just
wanted to eat and drink with you here
five grand they were five grand per
bottle are you [ __ ] me her a bottle
I'm tapped out were you there yeah I got
so trying to picture what the bottle
look like I forgot the beginning of
story yeah no we're just at dinner we're
at dinner and Winnipeg yes right yeah
and he's just sorry I'm back yeah yeah
and then he just in Winnipeg and I'm
drinking it not I'm like this is good
wine and like the big guy the guys like
yeah like the the server is like he's
like it's pretty good and you know and
then I'm like can I get another glass
but I'm full so I don't really drink it
and like this to full I think to finish
this last one and then and you knew it
was five grand no not yet that's the
thing and then the next day I actually
run into that guy the guy that served us
and I'm like so what's up with that wine
we drank he's like that's [ __ ] like
as good as wine as you can find in
though in the in the world and if he
tried to don't sleep on winner pick they
get great food yeah it's crazy [ __ ]
though and the one it's it's brutal it's
got the like dinner hold it's what they
call it at the spot the windiest coldest
spot in North America is an interstate
80 and say it's cold you know it's
[ __ ] unbelievably cold but you're
supposed to when you bought when you buy
a glass or bottle of wine like that I
didn't know this but the thing you're
supposed to do is you're supposed to
leave a little bit for the sommelier
that's like the refine thing to do what
for the guy that the wine expert for the
psalm you know - lets
it's like consider its like you he said
never get into smoking weed just that
whole passing of look can I have my own
buddy no no run yeah alright can I
Miller High Life theory what's that
alright is I don't give a [ __ ] that it
says there's twelve ounces of beer and
there there isn't I think this barely
ten there's something about that bottle
to it it just it just saw slender looks
like a [ __ ] eight of beers you know
how loves a champagne three sips and
it's gone yeah does your favorite beer
um I go like to dump white trash I like
regular Budweiser uh-huh I like Michelob
light it's the first beer I've got drunk
on so I got child since memory hammered
down if annual haul off at two beers yes
I like the closed and then Miller High
Life yeah all those [ __ ] new ones the
suffering bastard kick you in the face I
got like seven of them in there manly
neighbor yeah I just stayed Emma Chimay
is a good beer that's Helen by the bay
best cigar out there that I've ever had
xeno platinum chubby Z no platinum
chubby is one of the greatest cigars
I've ever had it was one of jay-z's
cigars I was like jay-z's [ __ ]
favorite cigars JZ I was gonna say like
the best cars I've ever seen a rap
rappers get jay-z's
Porsche yeah it's so [ __ ] clean dude
it's so [ __ ] it's a classic the
silver I saw him when he was people's
doing something at our clinic at 9/11 or
us yeah yeah is that that style but but
this I don't know what his just looks
just a little different it's just it's a
good good best friend and then I would
say [ __ ] great hey Wes his [ __ ]
Mercedes
did you ever see though he had no dude
he bought this [ __ ] thing was like a
million bucks it's like the Speed Racer
car
there's no windshield like you wear a
helmet with goggles and [ __ ] oh shut up
Judas got the little it's just like the
cockpit like you're in a plane yeah and
that's that little [ __ ] silver roll
bar over your head it's like the
Batmobile meets the Speed Racer thing
there's just another thing just have you
listeners Google Kanye West's Mercedes
the only thing was he pulled up to like
some premiere in it with this friend and
they would just sit there with their
heads coming out they look like two
black like Mike Ditka Michael Dukakis
you know he had his head outside the
tank look like you can drive the [ __ ]
you got a head like the goggles with the
helmet a scarf some sort of Steve
McQueen the AJ Foyt Mario Andretti vibe
with that car the car is still like like
that's one of those things yeah I mean I
mean I've never I've never seen anybody
I really seen Jay Leno does he know that
[ __ ] car
yeah favorite Jay Leno car you guys
watch his uh garage a lot oh yeah dude
he's got so many [ __ ] it's really
crazy came we were it's not it's not the
obvious ones either he's at this dot
does 70 something Datsun two-door yeah a
lot of hot rod guys with just it was
just a perfect [ __ ] little car we
could just slam a big engine in and it
was already light his [ __ ] and it's
really boxy looking remember those are
those Corollas and what was it whoops
Dodson's version of the Corolla I don't
know if I've Tannis I can't remember
like a 56 mg like all types all he's got
this and then he's got that
mercedes-benz limo mercedes-benz at one
point just said [ __ ] budget let's just
make and I'm paraphrasing you got to
watch the video that Jay has on and it's
like it's the stretch [ __ ] just sick
ass like these are the people that own
that car it was Elvis John Lennon had
one and then everybody else was like a
dictator and they were bulletproof all
right Jay Leno had that [ __ ] car dude
it's insane let it off he had one yeah
Edie I mean yeah the guys like that had
him with the curtains in the kitchen I
like the the 1967 Cadillac limo that the
stones were driving around in that's a
great one too [ __ ] beautiful
like that's what I wouldn't mind one of
those you know I saw one time there was
like a 1930s stretch like limo thing but
you you sit behind the back window and
it was a it was an old Cadillac was it
the 30s was it that old it might have
been the 40s yeah and I was and I was
joking with my wife going like oh if I
had the [ __ ] money the space and all
that I would redo this [ __ ] thing and
you could hire a driver just like the
old school the white gloves yeah get in
looking like new money bum that I look
like right just getting with my Bruins
t-shirt and sit in the [ __ ] back and
when if there just be funny [ __ ] yeah
when you pull up there oh who's getting
out of this it's just [ __ ] you know
whatever is this guy part of the I'm
trying to think
Randolph Hearst the [ __ ] third oh
just some dope like me gets out I love
driving but I love to have a driver
I love no driver it's the best oh I'd
love to have a driver get work done you
could rest all the time
[ __ ] everything would be better with
the driver in this town I'm gonna have
to reassess my uber because I'm spending
way too much on uber
I hate Hoover I like taxis really really
yeah cuz oversaw some 20-something kid
and they [ __ ] working on a script
they [ __ ] know who you are and then
they [ __ ] all this way you live it's
weird you get into a [ __ ] taxi nobody
knows who you are yeah oh that is true
I'd never thought about that yeah I know
you know where I live
yeah then people like what just happened
dropped me off for well then they still
know basically where you live right I
haven't tried maybe I'll take a taxi to
the store next time dude you can come
out of prison and get a job as a [ __ ]
uber driver you don't advertise right I
lost them on my podcast talking about
[ __ ] like this yeah drive with uber
while I was doing the read roll the dice
people no background check there's much
backlash did you get on the the
draftkings or whatever they didn't did
they call you they had to have write you
like this is game never get to me
they never are they call no advertising
that's great it's great being your own
boss
I'm never available never available for
the call yeah I just my whole thing is
if you didn't like the read I'll give
you money back I understand but like
like people make the mistake like like
for me the show doesn't stop when you go
into advertising we're also just gonna
skip over it so I walk around
around and the advertisers that get it
look like this is gonna make people keep
listening to it and maybe they'll buy
this [ __ ] or they'll just fast-forward
through the [ __ ] so they know that with
every read there's a chance you know
sometimes you know I had like a
predatory Bank on there or like there
was these guys you know claiming they
tried to claim that you know 40% of all
tickets to every live event go unsold
and I'm like yeah the Super Bowl every
year you know these guys get him somehow
because they yeah she only sells 60% of
the Rose Bowl that's a heavy book [ __ ]
out of here we just do [ __ ] like that
cuz I know the listeners they're not
dopes they're thinking that anyways yeah
so it just makes you look dumb if you're
going did you know yeah then you start
realizing you're like the [ __ ] like
me on these sent me some underwear
they're great they are like about you
hear so many people go there really
articles comfortable well underwear you
go that's what they're pants now that
they are really [ __ ] cold yeah
they're the best they're not my sponsor
but they're really [ __ ] comfortable I
got a whole jingle-jingle or B undies I
just think yeah but up beyond ease
beyond ease no more sweaty balls
biondi's me undies and whatever I'm
thinking of use promo code mining and
ammo for 20% off your first bundles
whatever do I piss in your yard or is
there a bathroom in the house oh just
piss in the yard okay maybe the me
undies jingle isn't that great is you
guys just talked all the way through it
just really lost all faith in that thing
all right should we wrap this up
isn't it amazing hot time I was just
like I was it's probably a quarter to
three two hours I did two hours when did
we like these two hours ago no it was
good I promise you yeah we looked at two
hours ago yeah this is a [ __ ] blast
oh it's a great time this is a great
[ __ ] time
Congrats on 200 buddy thank you yeah
little [ __ ] one heater with you
before we go what's that I'll have one
little heater
little little yeah well something both
sound of war me it just make the drive
home a little exciting
[Music]
you tell me well you shouldn't what say
you that's the last thing I remember
every year at the Rose Bowl Rose Bowl
every year see new money his top shelf
is like underneath his [ __ ] credenza
showing it off like a trophy we got here
Wow I'd like some of that look at that
right yeah
pokers come on that's beautiful when you
get nominated for an Emmy and you win on
one of your brilliant stand-up specials
when she rather if they just gave you a
bottle of that [ __ ] yeah man that's
stupid I go back to my 2.1 million
dollar house angel holding that thing
right next to the US Open whatever the
[ __ ] that is next oh [ __ ] this was given
to me this is one of the many
development deal promised it's gonna go
to series because we're definitely
shooting the pilot yeah yeah gift from a
production company that wanted to work
with me and then it just got [ __ ]
show no it's at NBC for the offer how
many pilots have you shot I've really
shot I've shot a million parts basic
story you've had for any anything I was
waiting to be like I was in Transylvania
and this gave me this no this one this
this is I think this is that a Colorado
maybe by the way anybody listening to
this this could be your life if you tell
some [ __ ] and dick jokes yeah yep middle
of the day what's today I know what
today is Tuesday who's that Miller Danna
Tuesday smells really good how eat are
we going I don't know
this should be like a two part of like
Physical Graffiti you know what I mean
so there should be the sober I'm just
spitballing here guys it's always a bit
bawling proof all right sort of do we do
we end the podcast and then enjoy this
like gentlemen a weekend you're not dude
you're not gonna slam this are you oh no
I'm gonna get a new glass why take a
look at my glass
what you do what is it looking bug in it
yeah but the booze kills it dude that
bug is hammered
could you imagine somebody dropped you
and like if you of the size of that fly
if you [ __ ] that's like one of those
water towers it was full of scotch and
they just threw you in it and you would
just do with a dead man's float in it he
died doing what he loved swimming in a
water tower a [ __ ] scotch I'll drink
that one later you guys are gone no he
didn't leave you would have got to see
me I was gonna take that lollipop there
and stick the stick in the end here is
the feed out Cassidy Garcia's the L
Castro story though how could we do okay
how could you get a podcast we just
smoke cigars and drink whistling give it
to you
so there's salute thank you guys for
doing this I appreciate it oh my god
it's really nice
whoa that's really nice it's really nice
Tom liked it I was waiting for like yeah
you know I like this party like it kind
of floral taste it first like say like
they even do with the cigars like I'm
tasting a chocolate yeah it's like are
you I'm tasting smoke and let's just
[ __ ] like that yeah yeah
every city bus should smell like a cigar
I missed that smoke when I was talking
to shame us about leave I'll almost
rather you smoke cigarettes in here cuz
at the vape pen like smelling cotton
candy you're just like nice feeling I'm
dying
oh they studies out there now really
about the damage they do yeah none of
which I've read I've just all of a
sudden you've seen a little movement in
the media now they're telling me it's
bad but you know it always goes back and
forth member eggs will good for you then
they're bad now they're good to get
another good then you just want the
white and then like oh no all the
proteins in the yolk yeah I loved my
grandfather at a Friday every day and
[ __ ] drank a martini at night and he
lived almost to be a hundred so what I
think it really is is when you just stop
doing what you do really quickly and
then you go to that what's that little
[ __ ] those little red things my wife
eats some pomegranate seeds yeah yeah
you start doing that like I'm gonna
cleanse myself it's just like a oh yeah
one of those I did one of those juice
cleanses and it [ __ ] my stomach up for
its to this day yeah you gotta go
vegetable if you go to the frontline
steel though I got a buddy might turn
into a diabetic doing that [ __ ] he was
able to knock it off good bike cutting
it off but he was thinking he was being
all healthy he just kept getting all the
ones with like the Apple he's doing like
three times a day and sugar went through
the [ __ ] roof holy [ __ ] yeah and he
went for a physical when they would told
me he was a diabetic I feel like an old
lady telling like urban myths right now
well you haven't closed the deal I gotta
take a piss back in [ __ ] Deadwood
days you couldn't you just have to drink
the whiskey all right you know many
dates you want to promote Tom dates yeah
I mean you'd crouch around the campfire
and they still had that ribbon right
where the taint was you know those
rivets that they have on the jeans yeah
back in the day they had one right right
down near the crotch but Cowboys when
they squadron campfire would get hot and
they burn their balls so they got rid of
it so that was the hot one holding your
inseam yeah rivet there yeah up the
taint oh shut the [ __ ] up dates
you got any dates you want to promote
any dates coming up sure I got a bunch
Tom Segura I come cuz they're all there
you know every great comic will not
[ __ ] promote themselves if you were
[ __ ] hack well you'd [ __ ] have all
you know all your dates or no dates I'm
in Tampa but this is already been posted
this is already happen I don't mean
Atlanta I have a gig in Gainesville
right Gainesville Yeah right before the
rightful seat of the gig Friday and then
the gig and then it's just like the
works out of the way and then we rent
like a little [ __ ] party bus I always
end up losing money and then till we
just because what I want to do that
going and then we know we reach out on
our podcast virzi Bartnik all these guys
lawhead we [ __ ] say hey man we're
looking for a tailgate we want to see
how you guys do it down there and then
people will send us [ __ ] pictures and
then just whoever has the sickest
looking smoker and looks the least like
a [ __ ] serial killer I'm gonna do it
is where called cold so you couldn't get
tickets to Bill show and I'm just gonna
do same cities as hell yes
and then just hang out with him Saturday
it's tough being humble you're a [ __ ]
TV star dude your show is [ __ ] great
yeah thank you Jim Jefferies virzi one
night we'll [ __ ] watching you're
doing something we just kept rewinding
because he's like totally afraid of
heights
yeah yeah one were you in that giant
soccer stadium and they just said you
swooping down and you're like we're
doing this with no setup lose this
Mabhida yo can I tell you I tried to
write a bit about that but because it
was such a weird experience to have
black guys harness you in like you don't
have black guys harness you in often
yeah is that stadiums usually getting
harnessed in by like you know Zealand
all right like Kearney people no no it's
always Aussies and Kiwis and then to
have black guys do it in the US and
knowing I when I jumped off of that
state who's all brothers of course it's
like the Richard Pryor joke you know I
went to Africa and everyone black the
dead my lights a black and he's just
like [ __ ] I never looked at it like this
and when you get when you're getting
harnessed in you're real like you're
like oh I've never seen a black guy jump
off [ __ ] like this right I'm not
comfortable with you guys harnessing me
in cuz I've never I've never seen black
guys always make fun of white guys cuz
we do [ __ ] like this and now they're
tighten me up and I just go do you want
to take a look and he's like you're good
like what no do you want to have that
someone else look at it you think no I
did it good let's go did you clarify I
was not I'm not English or Dutch who
took over yeah no ruin their lives down
there the Dutch and then and then he
needs me you'll see like this is so not
a white guy thing yeah but like as you
go to jump he needs you to get make sure
you clear it because he don't want you
to hit your head
ultimate yeah but it looks a lot like
he's just [ __ ] beat it but yeah that
was crazy and then I showed it to Hilah
and I was I was an interesting kid I
showed it to Island thinking she'd think
I was badass and then she gets up there
she sees me with all the black guys and
she goes is that the wu-tang clan
I could no it's not the wu-tang clan
baby yeah I gotta [ __ ] sit down and
try to write all those adventures I've
done ride him into an hour do you know
that a friend of mine works at a music
venue and he said it's like a venue that
you made pretty decent
okay I can't say which one but he said
they watch you know they have all these
music acts come in and he's like he's
like you know you're never you're just
like ah who cares and we had whoo tang
coming up and he's like there was just
like such a buzz amongst the staff yeah
that works there anyways they perform
everyone's all excited and a girl he
works with is like I'm gonna get on that
bus I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] one of
those guys and he's like the odds are
good I mean there's like 18 you sure you
want to do it and she's like yeah all
right she goes on failure
[Laughter]
[Music]
she's like and they're like do we need
to call the police or something she's
like no I did it voluntarily but they
were just so mean about so can you
imagine
dude I [ __ ] up dude that guy said we
need to call the police he's like yeah
what the [ __ ] did you know she was just
traumatized but you can imagine they
were just [ __ ] like she blew you god
in front of us probably everybody and
then Cappadonna was like what about me
I'm sweating Remo it's my favorite
memory of this year was hearing that
story the first time I'm a commit I just
it's just I get a bit it starts like you
saw heart and you got the [ __ ] the two
chicks we're back in the day right he's
like you would be crying like oh just
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that you know that's
not gonna come we should have stopped
her before that but like this isn't what
you think it's gonna be yeah you've got
stuff these packing through Vietnam
you're like it seems like a little idea
of it's a real lot harder
a lot of [ __ ] oh they must have not
sold out that night and they wanted just
a bad mood
you walk into all the I'll ship it in
and our bonus [ __ ] you got paid yeah
they're mad cuz it used to be nine
different girls yeah no it's just like
yeah and you imagine if you're like
number eight Europe you got a your
little salty by the time seriously
either to I the two hottest verses on
the last album there's no [ __ ] way I
should've an eight oh my god alright
yeah do you many dates you want to
promote Bill
I'm gonna be doing the women's festival
raise awareness oh I'm not getting out
of [ __ ] or bus
damn [ __ ] good that's really I'm
gonna be in Atlanta
what do you a letter I don't know
Tabernacle no Fox Theater and then I'm
doing something in Gainesville and as
always we always forget to get the hotel
rooms and you forget that a hundred
thousand people descending what do you
do place you stay in in a different City
oh and then you get a bus I want to do
next year I want to do get a bus go to a
Thursday night college game I'll do a
gig Friday go go to another game
Saturday and then do gigs throughout the
week and go one more Saturday like big
game I want to do like a attended I'm
trying to go to like all that every
[ __ ] school that has a football team
because I've already gone to every
professional sports team and the horse
sports other than like [ __ ] 20 of
them so now I'm down to college and I'm
just gonna try to go through all like
the divisions dude I was on the plane
looking up like the Mountain West
Division oh and I'm just like alright
they have almost eight schools it's like
Boise State Colorado Fresno State San
Jose State San Diego State Air Force
Hawaii you can be living North Dakota
state oh yeah I would definitely do I
walk there to go to a hockey game yeah
well yeah I go to Fargo people sleep on
those [ __ ] states like those first of
all the people are so [ __ ] psyched
that they finally have to drive all the
way out of Minneapolis for a gig that
you come there dude I'd better get gig
and Deadwood was the [ __ ] you did a [ __ ]
the goat show in Deadwood yeah they got
this [ __ ] place there that sells
these candies that liked all the [ __ ]
ritzy people out here when they have
like they like fly them in or some [ __ ]
you go in this little [ __ ] hole in
the wall thing all these chocolate so I
came back little box of chocolates for
my wife that's a big thing too when you
have a nice guys weekend in the Hat you
having a good time yeah you got to come
back with some macaroons or something
yeah just to [ __ ] be like yet there
was a moment there was awesome time when
I was away from you that I actually did
thought about yeah I'd like to do that
I'd like to figure my routing out more
than
sure sounds good no that's how I used to
do it when I used to get like all these
these college gigs I'm one of the best
days I had I went to a day game the
Milwaukee Brewers at County Stadium and
then I did my gig at night and then the
next day I drove up to like Minnesota
was my next gig and they had another day
game it was like on the weekend did a
Saturday and a Sunday and I went to the
old homered own the Minnesota Twins yeah
which was such a [ __ ] but like just
kirby puckett and all those all the
great games that I saw there and Rod
Carew oh he was all like she was on the
angels by then when I really started
watching him but like and I think the
Friday night I flew in early and went to
like a Cubs game or a White Sox game was
just [ __ ] was awesome baseball is
easy forever hoop has been hard how do
you how do you score most ticket so when
you go to any of these games ice is just
scalp back in the day when I just had
like the disposable camera yeah I am I
gotta find where they are I have like
these pictures of me by myself in front
of all these stadiums that no longer
exist yeah in the picture I'm gonna go
to the game by myself and the pictures
taken by a complete stranger
this is me Stan and they oh yeah this is
this English girl who married a buddy of
mine was saying that I should make a
coffee table book and call it Billy
no-mates
because that's like an expression when
they go to a pub and there's a guy
drinking in the corner of a look at
Billy no-mates over here so that's
hilarious I don't think it would
translate but now like we're going to
that record again
I've been bombing when you go to the
Florida game will you will you skill
akan StubHub or something yeah I don't
like hitting people up for [ __ ]
tickets not neither do I I hate that
horrible like one time when I was in I
got to know some guy who a guy who was
affiliated with the Yankees okay and I
used to go there all the [ __ ] time
then rooting against the Yankees I was
living in New York but I would go there
and I saw all those great to the 98
games I saw all those great teams and
the one time I ever hit him up was like
in August they were playing the Blue
Jays and Blue Jays sucked and I was just
like you know what I'm just gonna cuz I
hooked him up with some comedy tickets
yes like alright I'm gonna do this and
you know when they made money make the
playoffs if I want to go you know I'll
StubHub the thing but I'm not going to
hit
this guy up you know when it's just like
you know Game seven yeah you know can I
get two behind home plate as I'm not
[ __ ] I'm gonna be I'm not gonna be
that guy
yeah whether he's just like really dude
162 [ __ ] games in the year you don't
hit me up and all of a sudden you gonna
come by and [ __ ] October come on
just like that what was didn't you do
that gig we had to ride the bus and do
stand-up to get tickets I never did it
though you never did it Patrice was the
final blow really after they tried they
did a headlining set trashing me st
offered the gig it was two buses of
Braves fans going up in 1999 or
something like that was a 2000 on that
no 2000 they played the Mets 99 yeah and
I'd never been a World Series game I was
so excited and that the gig wouldn't
have been bad yeah all you had to do was
just [ __ ] on the [ __ ] Yankees mean
the traffic would be rough yeah and I
would just trash New York the whole whip
it would have been a [ __ ] easy gig so
as much as they made us but they just
unbeknownst to me
Norton turn the gig down and I'm sitting
at the [ __ ] table at the cellar and
all the killers were there it was
Patrice rest his soul Keith Robinson
Kevin Hart rich vos Jim Norton each one
of them could have done a half hour
alone thrashing me and they were all
together like the wu-tang clan informed
dude they started thrashing me and I
fought back for about a minute and I
just I just sat there I just got I got
destroyed and I'd already given the gig
to somebody else
yeah and I kept my mouth shut and didn't
say I I'm not doing it I gave it to
so-and-so and I made like a promise I
would never say who did it and then he
actually outed himself that he actually
did was it yeah as Steve Byrne did it
Steve or did it and I go how was it he
goes dude it was [ __ ] brutal but he
goes when I got that ticket I just
[ __ ] jet and I go was it awesome he
goes oh yeah it was totally [ __ ]
worth it
so but after the end of the thrashing
dude like they were trashing me so bad
complete strangers who committed they're
trashing you for accepting the gig yeah
oh they were like so bill when they
bring you up how you're gonna come out
of the bathroom you're gonna walk up
those little stairs it was an hour of
that you're gonna grab like the
microphone like the bus driver is gonna
be like okay
alone up but first and and then the tree
said the best one this is like a visual
joke and use this like how you gonna
finish your set and he just like had me
facing the [ __ ] bus the crowd in the
bus and I just go like thanks a lot you
guys have been great and then I sit down
just going like yeah hey thanks a lot
dude it was a [ __ ] hour of that and
all these people I didn't know we're
either laughing or going like oh the
people don't aw was even worse and I
just sat there and I took it and like
the beating was so bad I so wanted to
tap out and say burn did it but yeah I
just took it like a man yeah and dude
sixteen years later I finally said it
cuz I even even when he said that he
ended up doing the gig
yeah I didn't stand up at a [ __ ]
minor league game minor lead and Godfrey
set it up serious it was Ricky Ricky
Henderson's triple AAA game where he
came out he dogs he was playing with the
San Diego Sea Dogs
really yeah man it was worth it so the
heavy to stand up before the game
started while all the players are
standing outside of the dugouts watching
me and then they it was so painful where
were you on the pitchers mom I was yeah
pick a base only doing this if I'm
second base they go you're gonna come
back after I finish they're gonna come
back during the seventh-inning stretch I
turned and I was like there's no [ __ ]
way there's no way he's like he can't
they can't [ __ ] do it where's your
[ __ ] idea but dude you're not you're
not like baseball apple pies Chevrolet
bring you eight year old kid no vasanta
core comes out you [ __ ] in the crowd
I guess you're gonna make you kid play
baseball instead of football all right I
got a piece so I hope your daughter's
suck the wu-tang
everybody dogs alright let's wrap this
up but I'm happy 200 happy - thank you
guys thank you so much for doing this
how appreciative no worries
I love
[Music]
you